AND WELCOME EVERYONE I'M SORRY
WE'RE STARTING A LITTLE LATE M.
USUALLY DON'T LIKE TO DO THAT
BUT IT'S ALMOST FUN TO HAVE
EVERYBODY IN SAN DIEGO SO- MY
NAME IS ASSEMBLYWOMAN LORENA
GONZALEZ AND I REPRESENT EIGHTY
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT IN SAN DIEGO
AND SHARE THIS ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON LET THE NIGHT
INEQUITIES I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL FOR JOINING US TODAY
WHETHER IT'S IN PERSON OR
VIRTUALLY TOWARD THIRD
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS BY THE
SELECT COMMITTEE. TODAY WILL
HEAR FROM EXPERTS AND WORKER
TESTIMONY ON THE IMPACT OF THE
LATINO PAY GAP WE WILL ALSO
HEAR ABOUT THE STATE'S EXISTING
PROTECTIONS FOR WORKER'S
EFFORTS TO ADVANCE EQUAL PAY
AND ANY POLICY RESPONSES
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
CONSIDERATION BEFORE WE GET
STARTED A FEW HOUSEKEEPING
THINGS M. ALTHOUGH WE ARE IN
THE COUNTY CHAMBERS WE ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE IN COMPLIANCE
WITHIN FIFTEEN ASSEMBLY
PROTOCOLS PLEASE WILL DO IT FOR
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS I'M NOT
GONNA SAY FOR THE AUDIENCE I
HOPE I DON'T GET IN TROUBLE FOR
THAT ONE WHAT WILL BITE BITE
CAL SAN DIEGO'S ORDERS- SINCE
WE ARE. MORE VACCINATED- THEN
THE REST OF THE STATE WE HAVE A
LITTLE MORE LEEWAY HERE.
HEARING AROUND ME. YOU KNOW. BE
CLOSE TO EACH OTHER AT YOUR OWN
RISK AND NOT WEAR MASK AT YOUR
OWN RISK. AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE
THAT TWO PANELS TODAY WITH THE
PEER OF TIME FOR MEMBER OF
QUESTIONS AND DISCUSSIONS FOR
EACH PANEL PUBLIC COMMENT WILL
TAKE PLACE AFTER THE SECOND
PANEL IN THE HEARING WILL END
PROMPTLY AT TWO THIRTY PM. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE CALL THE TOLL
FREE NUMBER AT. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE ONE EIGHT
FIVE ZERO THIS NUMBER CAN ALSO
BE FOUND THE ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE
UNDER TODAY'S EVENTS. I'D LIKE
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
JOINING US TODAY IN SAN DIEGO
AND THE COMMISSION ON THE
STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS FOR
THE PARTNERSHIP IN HOSTING THIS
HEARING. TODAY MARKS EQUAL PAY
DAY WHICH MEANS LATINOS HAVE
HAD TO WORK NATIONALLY ALMOST
TWENTY THREE MONTHS TO EARN
WHAT THEIR WHITE MALE
COUNTERPARTS EARNED IN JUST
TWELVE MONTHS. DESPITE
ACCOUNTING FOR CLOSE TO A ONE
TRILLION DOLLAR IN U. S. BUYING
POWER LOOKING ACROSS THE CAP
COUNTRY IN IN CALIFORNIA
CONTINUE TO EARN THE LOWEST
WAGES ON AVERAGE FORTY TWO
CENTS. ON THE DOLLAR. EVERY
YEAR. THANK YOU SWEETHEART.
EVERY YEAR WE CELEBRATE IF YOU
WILL I GUESS IT KNOWLEDGE. WITH
CLINICAL PAYDAY AS THE DAY WE
FINALLY REACH PARITY WITH THE
OTHER GROUPS BUT EVERY YEAR WE
ARE ALWAYS THE LAST EQUAL
PAYDAY. ENABLE MEANS LESS
INCOME FEW OPPORTUNITIES FOR
GROWTH AND LESS ECONOMIC
SECURITY FOR LATINOS AND THEIR
FAMILIES WHO MAKE UP 20% OF THE
STATE'S POPULATION. THIS IS WHY
IT'S SO IMPORTANT PRIORITIZE A
SUCCESS OF LETTING US. LAST
YEAR SPEAKER ANTHONY RENDON ON
APPOINTED ME TO CHAIR THE
SELECT COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS THE
CONTINUED GROWING INEQUALITY
LEVINE AS EXPERIENCE IN THE
STATE I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DISCUSSION TODAY. AND BEFORE WE
BEGAN- SINCE WE ARE IN HER HOME
AND THAT SHE IS HISTORIC IN HER
OWN RIGHT I WILL INVITE- I
WOULD SAY MY SUPERVISOR.
ALTHOUGH TECHNICALLY I LIVE
WITH MY SUPERVISOR SO AT. THE
SUPERVISOR WHO REPRESENTS AT
THE MAJORITY OF THE PORTION OF
MY DISTRICT- THE VICE CHAIR OF
THE COUNTY BOARD SUPERVISORS
NOR VARGAS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLARS. OUT
FIRST AND FOR WELCOME EVERYONE
TO OUR BEAUTIFUL CHAMBERS HERE
AT THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS I AM SO HAPPY TO
SEE SO MANY BEAUTIFUL LATINA
FACES- AS OF DECEMBER MENTIONED
I HAVE THE HONOR AND THE
PRIVILEGE OF BEING THE FIRST
LATINA. ON THE SENATE KIND OF
WHAT OUR SUPERVISORS AND THAT
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE YEAR
HISTORY. SO IT'S AN HONOR TO
HELP I THINK I THINK THIS WILL
BE EQUITY WHEN THEY WHEN
THERE'S ALL UP ENOUGH ON THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. AT LEAST
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
BUT ANYWAY I JUST WANTED TO
SAY. THANK YOU TO THE ASSEMBLY
I ASSEMBLY WOMAN. WHO HAS BEEN
A FIERCE IT CHAMPION AND
ADVOCATE. I'M NOT ONLY
RECOGNIZING HOW IMPORTANT THIS
STATE IS BUT- YOU KNOW. EVERY
DAY SHE WAKES UP AND ENSURES
THAT NOT ONLY WORKERS BUT OUR
COMMUNITY AND I'M CREATORS HAVE
ACCESS AND OPPORTUNITIES. TO
BETTER QUALITY OF LIFE. SO I
COULD NOT BE HAPPIER TO BE HERE
WITH HER TODAY AND LIKE I SAID
WELCOME ALL OF YOU. AND ALL OF
OUR- LEGISLATORS WHO ARE GONNA
BE. YOU KNOW THE BEAUTY OF THE
WORK THAT ALL OF YOU DO IS THAT
NOT ONLY ARE YOU GOING TO HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY HERE FROM PEOPLE
BUT THEN YOU. ALSO BACK IT UP
WITH ACTIONABLE ITEMS IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THAT'S WHO YOU
ARE THAT'S WHAT ALL OF YOU HAVE
BEEN AND I'VE BEEN. I'VE HAD
THE PUBLIC PLEASURE OF WORKING
WITH ALL OF YOU FOR MANY YEARS
AND SO- I WILL GO THROUGH MORE
STATISTICS OR ANYTHING ELSE
LIKE THAT I JUST WANTED TO SAY
WELCOME TO THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO AND THANK YOU FOR THE-
YOU KNOW THE- COURAGE AND THE
BRAVERY TO THE WORK THAT YOU DO
EVERY DAY. ON BEHALF OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND- THE OTHER
THING THAT I SHOULD MENTION IS
THAT I'M ALSO THE FIRST PERSON
WHOEVER. SPEAKS SPANISH ON THE
DIETS AND FOR ME IT'S REALLY
I'VE MAKE IT'S VERY PROP I'M
VERY PROUD TO DO THAT BECAUSE-
LARGE PORTION ESPECIALLY OF
OURS THAT. WHAT I WAS AND WHAT
IT IS. NOR LEARNING LESSON
POSES MA'AM WHICH ALLOWS DON'T
CRISTINA CHAOTIC ON THE
SUPPOSED AGAINST OF. THE NAME
PUT ANY OTHER THAT THE NET ON
THIS IS. EAST YES ARE SOME OF
ME DOES ALLOW. LESS IS A POORLY
REALLY SPOKE. BUT A FEDERAL
GOING TO SEND OUT THAT LOT OF I
LOCAL POLICE GUYS. YOU FOR
MARCH. WORKING AS GAY BUT I
COULD BELIEVE GOSPEL GOSPEL
AFTERNOON. WE GET ON THE STUFF
MONEY I. BUT I THINK I'M HERE
BECAUSE I'M I'M LOOKING AND I
TO GET. THEM TO THE MOST IS I
LOVE YOU MANY OTHER SUPPORT
WHEN I IN THE I'M A BILL OKAY
YOU DON'T. BACK AT THE BUT ALL.
IS GAS AND SO WITH- WELL. FOR
HAVE TO GO TO MEETING BUT YOU
IN THIS IS YOUR YOUR HOME
NEWCASTLE. AND IN ANYTHING THAT
I CAN TO SUPPORT. YOU AS ALWAYS.
YOU. ASSEMBLY WOMAN QUE L. AND
THEN WE'LL GO DOWN THE AISLE.
BUT TURN IT ON OKAY OKAY FINE.
I THINK IT'S ON CAN HEAR ME AT
THE TIME WELL AND GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE AND THANK
YOU TO OUR CHAIRWOMAN ASSEMBLY
WOMAN GONZALEZ FOR THE
INVITATION TO COME TO SAN
DIEGO- AS WE CELEBRATE AND
RECOGNIZE THE AMAZING
CONTRIBUTIONS OF LATINOS HAVE
DONE TO OUR STATE AND TO THE
COMMENTS OF THE SUPERVISOR
VARGAS- REPRESENTATION MATTERS
I HAPPEN TO BE- THE FIRST
IMMIGRANT SALVADORIAN FORMALLY
UNDOCUMENTED WOMAN ELECTED TO
THE STATE LEGISLATURE IN
SACRAMENTO MY UNDERSTANDING. IS
THAT THERE ARE ONLY TWO SELLING
US TO SALVADORAN WOMEN LET THE
MATH ELECTED TO STATE
LEGISLATURES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. AND SO WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT- BUILDING A BENCH IT
STARTS WITH US AND WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE AND SO I'M JUST
HONORED TO BE ABLE TO BE HERE
AND LINDA VOICE AND PERSPECTIVE
TO THIS CONVERSATION TODAY WITH
ANTHOLOGY SOLIDARITY. TO
DENOUNCE THE RACIAL IMPLICIT
BIAS THAT WE FACE INTO MANY
ASPECTS OF OUR SOCIETY
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
INCOME AND INCOME INEQUALITY WE
CAN ALL SHARE THE STORIES OF
MOMENTS THAT WE FELT
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST AND FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE FELT THAT PAIN.
KNOW THAT YOU HAVE STRONG
ADVOCATES IN CALIFORNIA
FIGHTING FOR EQUITY AND
INCLUSION AND SO I THINK THIS
THIS HEARING- AND MANY THAT
WE'VE DONE ACROSS THE STATE.
AND IN FACT MENTAL PARTICULAR
LANDED IN PORTLAND IN AN
IMPORTANT VOICE TO A MUCH
NEEDED CONVERSATION I'M HONORED
TO BE HERE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MAJORITY LEADER. VEHICLE MATH
THANK YOU SO MUCH I ALSO WANT
TO THANK OUR CHAIR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LADONNA GONZALEZ YOU ALL
KNOW THIS I DON'T NEED TO TELL
YOU BUT SHE'S SUCH A FIERCE
ADVOCATE JUST NOT ONLY FOR SAN
DIEGO BUT FOR ALL WOMEN AND ALL
OF THE NICE. IT'S SUCH A IT'S
SUCH AN HONOR TO SERVE WITH HER
AND TO FEEL. WHEN SHE UP LIVES
ALL OF US SO SHE UPLIFTS US AS
HER COLLEAGUES I KNOW SHE'S
UPLIFTING EVERYONE OF YOU AND
I'M EXCITED ABOUT TODAY'S
HEARING- ESPECIALLY TO HEAR
FROM THE PANELISTS ABOUT THE
IMPACT ON THE LATINOS WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE PAY
GAP. AND THEN ALSO TO HEAR
ABOUT THE EQUAL PAY AND
RECOMMENDATIONS I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO ALL OF THIS THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY WOMAN GARCIA
THANK YOU I'LL BE BRIEF I UST
WANT TO THANK. THE CHAIR OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE SOME ROOM AND
SALAS FOR HER TIRELESS WORK
AND- WELL BEFORE SHE WAS IN THE
LEGISLATURE BUT I'VE I'VE SEEN
A PERCENT FOR THE LAST- NINE
YEARS AND SO. EXCITED TO BE
HERE AND EXCITED FOR THE WORK
I'M SURE COLLEAGUES ARE GOING
TO EMBARK ON NEXT YEAR TO
CONTINUE TO BE INTENTIONAL. AS
MY COLLEAGUE- BOERNER HORVATH
WAS SPEAKING ABOUT EARLIER TO
HER LEGISLATION THANK YOU. YEAH
YES THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
CONVENING US I THINK PART OF
WHAT WE DO IN SACRAMENTO IS TO
BRING VISIBILITY M. PART OF IT
IS TO BRING CHANGE BUT WE CAN'T
DO THAT UNLESS WE COME TOGETHER
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
WHO BROUGHT US TOGETHER SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT I KNOW I
REPRESENT NORTH COUNTY AND I
KNOW WHEN I GO OUT AND I TALK
TO PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITIES I
HAVE ELECTED OFFICIALS I HAVE
EXECUTIVES AND ALL MY LATINOS
TOMMY I FEEL ON SCENE. AND PART
OF THE REASON THEY FEEL AND
SEEN AS THEY ARE DISMISSED AND
THE DISMISSAL SHOWS UP IN THAT
PICKUP SO WHEN WE'RE DEALING
WITH THE PICK UP WE'RE NOT
DEALING WITH JUST MONEY IN
DOLLARS AND CENTS WE'RE DEALING
WITH THE ENTIRE CULTURE WHERE
WE VALUE PEOPLE AND LATINOS IN
OUR COMMUNITY SERVER FOR TO BE
PART OF THIS CONVERSATION THANK
YOU FOR INVITING ME HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU AND I KNOW WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- JONES SAWYER
HERE AS WELL HE WILL JOIN US I
THINK HE JUST STEPPED OUT FOR
A- HOT SECOND BUT- HE IS HERE.
AS A LOT AND I WANTED TO
RECOGNIZE HIM WITH THAT WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND START THIS
WHAT IT'S ABOUT. THE HEARING
THE TESTIMONY OF FOLKS WHO CAN
TELL US WHAT'S GOING ON AND-
WHAT WE CAN DO TO. MAKE THIS
BETTER. FIRST UP WE HAVE SARAH
CRAWFORD WITH THE NATIONAL
WOMEN'S LAW CENTER WHO WILL SET
THE STAGE AND PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF WHAT IS THE PAY
GAP. PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE
READY SARAH. VIRTUALLY. OKAY
HELLO CAN YOU ALL HEAR ME. YES
OKAY I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY HI THERE BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL WOMEN'S LAW CENTER
NATIONALLY WE MARC LEVINE EQUAL
PAY DAY RECOGNIZE THAT
ACCIDENTS HAPPEN WORK I YEAR
AND TEN MONTHS JUST MAKE AS
MUCH AS WHITE NON HISPANIC MEN
WERE PAID IN ONE YEAR ALONE
HOWEVER IN CALIFORNIA HEY I
HAVE THE EVEN GREATER AND BACK
CALIFORNIA HAS THE LARGEST
CATHOLIC HEATED COUNTRY MEANING
THAT HE HAD IN THE STATE WOULD
HAVE TO WORK WARRANT. YEARS AT.
AND CALIFORNIA. THE CAJUN FORTY
TEN FOR EVERY DOLLAR PAID WHITE
NON HISPANIC MEN. MEDIAN LATINO
IN THE IN A ROW THIRTY THOUSAND
AND OVER SEVENTY DOLLARS AN
HOUR. FOR WHITE AND HISPANIC
MEN IF YOU HAVE A HAD A- CHANCE
DIFFERENT OF OVER EIGHT HUNDRED
EVERY MONTH OVER FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS EVERY YEAR. AND OVER
ONE EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS OF
THE COURSE OF A YEAR. HE
HESPERIAN. FOR LIKE THE END THE
FAMILY. NATIONWIDE 15% AT ALL
AT THE END. YEAH SARAH I'M
SORRY WE FOR SOME REASON WE
CAN'T HEAR AND I DON'T KNOW
VERY WELL I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
US OR YOU'LL- I'M- TRYING TO
PULL MY- GET CLOSER TO THE
MICROPHONE MAYBE. IS THAT A
LITTLE BIT BETTER. I I'D
SUGGEST MAYBE TRYING TO TURN
OFF YOUR VIDEO INTEREST USING
AUDIO SO WE CAN HEAR. THAT THAT
SOUNDED BETTER. I'M NOT REALLY.
IS IT. HER CONNECTION ARE OURS
TO BE NOW. IF THE INTERNET
CONNECTION. THIS IS WHY WE WORK
SO HARD THIS YEAR TO PUT A LOT
OF MONEY INTO BROADBAND
SERVICES FOR EVERYBODY BECAUSE
THESE ARE THE ISSUES WE FACE.
CHOI. WHY DON'T WE DO THIS WHY
DON'T WE MOVE ON- TO AN IN
PERSON TESTIMONY WILL SEE IF
THERE IS IT WILL COME BACK TO
FAIR AND SEE IF THAT WORKS
BETTER BECAUSE I CAN'T. HEAR I
DON'T KNOW IF THE- SHE CAN DIAL
IN. THAT MIGHT BE A GOOD IDEA.
G. OKAY SO WORK ON GETTING
SERRA DIALED IN. TO A PHONE
LINE AND IN THE MEANTIME WE'LL
HAVE THEM. PLEASE ORTEGA'S
SPEAK LIVE AS EXECUTIVE
SECRETARY TREASURER AT THE
ALAMEDA LABOR COUNCIL AND THE
FIRST LATINA TO BE ELECTED THIS
POSITION THE COUNCIL'S HISTORY
SHE'S GOING TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT MORE AND WE WILL GO ACK TO
SERRA VIA PHONE LINE HOPEFULLY-
AFTER THIS. IS WHEN I STARTED
THERE AS SO AMAZING TO BE HERE
I THANK YOU SO MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LORENA GONZALEZ FOR
INVITING US AND INVITING LABOR
TO BE PART OF THE CONVERSATION.
AS YOU MENTIONED I AM I LIVES
ARE TAKE A TARON EXECUTIVE
SECRETARY TREASURER OF THE
ALAMEDA LABOR COUNCIL ALL THE
WAY DOWN FROM THE BEAUTIFUL BAY
AREA RAINY AND COLD. TWO
BEAUTIFUL SAN DIEGO- AND
EXCITED TO BE HERE AND EXCITED
TO SEE SO MANY BEAUTIFUL FIERCE
FALL WONDERFUL WOMEN WHO ARE
DOING THE WORK THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN EVERY SINGLE DAY. I'M AT
THE LABOR LEADER I REPRESENT A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND UNION MEMBERS IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY MANY OF THEM.
WOMEN THAT LOOK LIKE US. AND
I'M ALSO THE FIRST IMMIGRANT
LATINA TO BE ELECTED TO THIS
POSITION AND WHILE IT'S AN
HONOR AND A PRIVILEGE FOR ME
EVERY DAY IT'S EVEN MORE FOR MY
MOTHER AND MY FATHER WHO CAME
AND BROUGHT ME TO THIS COUNTRY.
WHEN I WAS THREE YEARS OLD AS
AN UNDOCUMENTED CHILD AND THEY
FOUGHT HARD- TO GIVE MY
BROTHER'S AN IDOL THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE IN FRONT
OF YOU TODAY. AND SO. TODAY I
WANTED TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT A WOMAN THAT I ADMIRE IN
ADDITION TO LEARNING GONZALEZ.
FORTY YEARS AGO A YOUNG LATINA
FARMWORKERS BEGAN HER CAREER AS
A UNION ORGANIZER. SHE
DEDICATED HERSELF TO ORGANIZE
THE MARTINEZ WORKING IN THE
GARMENT INDUSTRY SWEATSHOPS IN
LOS ANGELES. YEARS LATER SHE
TURNED LEFT THE NOVEL TELL
HOUSEKEEPERS INTO POLITICAL
POWER HOUSES. TODAY MONEY AND
THEN I DO WHAT I FEEL IS A
STATE SENATOR. AND WHEN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ IS
HELP. MONEY AND THEN I WON A
LOT THAT GUARANTEES DECENT PAY.
FOR LATINOS IN THE GARMENT
INDUSTRY. BEFORE I BE THE
LEADER OF THE ALAMEDA LABOR
COUNCIL I ALSO WORK FOR ASK ME
LOCAL THIRTY TWO NINETY NINE.
THEN I REPRESENT WORKERS AND
WHAT OF THAT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM WOMEN OF
COLOR JOAQUIN AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA SYSTEM THE
STATE'S LARGEST THIRD LARGEST
EMPLOYER. BUT FOR ALL THE
PRESTIGE THAT THE UNIVERSITY
HAS IT WAS THERE THAT I
LEARNED. A LOT THE NEXT CLEAN
THE TOILETS AND COOK THE FOOD
FOR THE STUDENTS AND THE
FACULTY AND THE ADMINISTRATORS
HAVE ONE OF THE WORST PAY GAPS
IN THE COUNTRY. AND THAT THE
NOT GETTING HIRED AT UC WILL
WORK SIX YEARS. FIFTY YEARS
BEFORE SHE EARNS WHAT A WHITE
MAN HIRED AS A SERVICE WORKER
GETS PAID ON HIS FIRST DAY AND
THIS IS WHAT THE UNION CONTRACT.
I DON'T NEED TO TELL YOU WHY.
BECAUSE EVERYONE OF YOU
EVERYONE IN HERE INCLUDING
MYSELF HAS EXPERIENCED RACISM
AND SEXISM. JUST LIKE OUR
MOTHERS HAVE JUST LIKE OUR
SISTERS HAVE JUST LIKE MY
DAUGHTER HAS AND MANY OTHERS.
RECENTLY THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCE BOARD PUBLISHED A
DOCUMENT. ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE
AND WHAT LOCAL COMMUNITIES HAVE
TO DO ABOUT IT. IN THAT
DOCUMENT THE STATE REFER TO US
AS THE SERVICE POPULATION. THE
SERVICE POPULATION REALLY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAT'S WHO WE
ARE. THE WOMEN WHO COOK FOR
THEM CLEAN AND TAKE CARE OF THE
KIDS WERE JUST A SERVICE
POPULATION. ON TOP OF THE
ALREADY EXISTING WAGE GAP THAT
WE'VE HEARD OVER AND OVER TODAY
THE PANDEMIC HAVE IMPACTED
LATINOS HARDER THAN ANY OTHER
WORKERS. WHAT TURNS AND SERVICE
INDUSTRIES HARD HIT BY THE
PANDEMIC THE NUMBER OF LET THE
NATS OF LAUGHTER JOBS HAVE
INCREASED AND WITH THAT LOSS
CAME THE LAST HAVE HEALTH
INSURANCE. MONEY TO PAY FOR
RENT FEED THEIR KIDS PAY THEIR
UTILITIES WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK
TO DO. MY MESSAGE TODAY IS
SIMPLE IF WE DON'T DEAL WITH
SENATOR MURRAY I'M AN ADULT THE
RUSSELL HAS DONE FOR AS LONG AS
SHE'S DONE. THEN WE WILL CLOSE
THE PAY GAP. BUT IT MIGHT A
LANA IS NOT THE EXCEPTIONAL
WOMEN SHE IS AN EXCEPTIONAL
WOMAN SORRY SHE IS AN
EXCEPTIONAL WOMAN BUT SHE
SHOULDN'T BE THE EXCEPTION TO
THE RULE. WE NEED TO BECOME THE
NEW ROLE IN THIS ROOM TODAY. I
FIGHTING AS HARD AS HER AND
THAT'S HARD ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ TO ENSURE THAT WE
WRITE THE RULES THAT WE HELP
AND THAT WE HELP CLOSE THE GAP
AND THAT WE DON'T MOVE
BACKWARDS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU LIZ AM I AND I THINK
EVERY EVERYBODY ON THIS SAD
PANEL WORKED REALLY HARD ON THE
BILL SO IT IS THANK YOU FOR
POINTING THAT OUT I THINK IN
FACT EVERY ON THE PANELISTS CO
AUTHORS OF THAT BILL. M. ON. AT
THE GOVERNMENT WORKER BILL
WHICH WAS A HUGE SUCCESS I'M
NOT GUARANTEEING EQUAL PAY BUT
DURING TEEN AT MINIMUM WAGE GO
FIGURE WE START JOBS THAT
LEVINE AS A HOLD IN THE STATE
THAT ARE GUARANTEED EVEN THE
BASICS OF MINIMUM WAGE-
HISTORICALLY. HELD BY LATINOS
INCLUDING DOMESTIC WORK AND I'M
GOVERNMENT WORK WITH THAT WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK TO TRY TO SEE
IF WE CAN TRY AGAIN WITH SARAH
CRAWFORD AND GET- THE- COUNTY
TECH PEOPLE ARE TELLING ME SHE
KEEPS TALKING IT'LL WORK ITS
WAY OUT. RIGHT THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO TRY ALL RIGHT
SARAH. OKAY WELL I DID CALL IN
CAN YOU ALL HEAR ME NOW. YES
THE BETTER OKAY- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL WOMEN'S LAW CENTER
NATIONALLY WE MARK LACKING
EQUAL PAY DAY RECOGNIZE THAT
LIKE YEAH WE WOULD HAVE TO WORK
A YEAR IN TEN MONTHS. YEAH TO
MAKE AS MUCH AS A WHITE MAN IN
THE BAND OF MEN WERE PAID IN
ONE YEAR ALONE. HOWEVER IN
CALIFORNIA HE ADDED EVEN
GREATER. YEAH HELP HAS A
LARGEST GAP WE'RE LOOKING IN.
MEANING THAT I'VE SEEN IN A
STATEMENT HAVE TO WORK MORE
THAN TWO YEARS AFTER. IN
CALIFORNIA. ARCADE JANET FORTY
CENTS AT FOR EVERY. PAID TO
WHITE NON HISPANIC MEN. MEDIAN
PAY AT THE END OF THE STATE IS
AROUND THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS COMPARED OVER SEVENTY
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS. FOR
WHITE MEN HISPANIC MEN. SAID
YEAH IN CASE YOU HAVE A GREAT
AMOUNTS TO A DIFFERENT KIND OF
OVER THIRTY EIGHT HUNDRED
DOLLARS EVERY MONTH. OVER FORTY
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS EVERY YEAR
AND ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS. OVER THE FOR THE
CAREER. THE VOLUNTARY HAVE.
USES FOR THAT HE IS AFFAIR. THE
FIFTEEN FOR OF ALL THAT IN THE
EARLY ONE AND I SO TO LIVE IN.
YOU KNOW AND I AN- ARM LIKELY
THAN WHITE NINE MEN AND WOMEN
BEHIND THE RIGHT OR MORTGAGE
PAYMENT AND HELPFUL SAVINGS IN
ADDITION. AND LAW WE WENT INTO.
I OKAY NEED LAST HAD HAD LEFT
MY TO COVER THEIR EXPENSES AND-
WHEN EVERY PENNY COUNTS. IT
ALSO HAS REALLY EFFECT THAT
NEED THAT HE MADE YEAH UNITY
RATHER LIKE THE BILL WELL. AND
FUTURE ECONOMIC BECAUSE EVEN
AND THEIR. NO WAY GAP MEANS
THAT MANY LACKING NOT THAT GOES
FOR TODAY PAYMENT ON HOME.
ACCORDING PAPER HIRING. YEAH
MINUTES WORTH FROM THE TIME.
BUT PANDEMIC IT ONLY WORSE AS
VERY FOR UNIT AND EVERYTHING.
IN IT BEGAN MAY LISTINGS HAPPEN
TO. JEFF FLOCK FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS SCHOOL HEALTHCARE TO AND
MANAGING OTHER RESPONDED. MANY
HAVE LOST JOBS HIGHER. EVAN LOW
HIM RETURN TO WORK IN A
THEMSELVES WITH NO OTHER THAN
TAKE LO QUE. LOW JOBS. THE
HOBBIT EDUCATION AND TRAINING
THAT WILL ALLOW TO ADVANCE. TO
A CAREER. FIELD MAY BE ADDED
REACH YEAH FACT IT RAISES
PRICES SHOULD BE FOR YEARS-
EXACTLY EXISTING AND GENDER
WAGE. NO PROBLEM OKAY FOR THAT
UNIT IN PERVASIVE AN INMATE AT.
HEALTH SOLUTION THAT ADDRESS
THE ROOT CAUSES. WHEN OF COLOR
ARE LESS FOR THE SAME WORK AND
REMAIN IN A KERR. WE REVEALS
THAT HAD A PROBLEM AFTER LIKE
REGION UNIT. AND WORK
OCCUPATION IN. CAN PORTION OF
THE AT REMAINS UNEXPLAINED AND
IT CERTAINLY IS FIVE THE ENEMY
O'CLOCK. YEAH YOU ARE OVER THAT
HE LOVE WAY JOBS AND- EVERY
MINUTE IN THE WEEK THAT IS
UNDER THEN AND I HATE OUT.
OFTEN LEADS HAS OF RATHMANN
INDETERMINATES. WHEN IN MAY ALL
HAVE THAT RATE OF YOU. ARE.
HERE ARE VERY AGAIN IT'S A FAIR
AND WE LOWER PAYING MODERN ART
LESS THAN FIVE AND THE MOTHER
WE TIME WILL BE IN A LARGER
BELOW WERE. HI OF HEALTHCARE
AND LACK OF HEAT MANY IT LESS
LIKELY THAT MANY MEDICARE
MEMBERS. ARE ABLE TO STAY THE
WORKFORCE. THAT HE NEEDED
ACTION. THAT CLOSE THE WAY SAM.
WE NEED POLICY THAT CENTER
ABILITY AND FAMILY. WE TO
EXPAND EDUCATIONAL ENOUGH FOR
THAT ALLOW AND HIGHER PAYING.
WE TO REMOVE AND INTO MAIL THE
FIELD WE TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE
LAW IN A THAT THAT I AND BUY
BACK. HE'S GOING TO. WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THE OF THE HE IS A
LOCATE BY RAISING MINIMUM. WE
CANNOT PREDICT WORKERS TO JOIN
YOU AND COLLECT. WE NEED TO
STRENGTHEN LEGAL. AGAINST
WORKPLACE HARASSMENT. AFTER TO
THE COUNTRY AND THAT HEALTH
INCLUDING REGRET CARE. WE MIGHT
PREVENT ANY RANDY GETTING HURT
AND MAGAZINES TURNING. WE
ESTABLISH KERR PRACTICES AND
EXPANDING A LITTLE OF HIGH
QUALITY AND AFFORDABLE
CHILDCARE. WE ACCESS PAY YEAH
AND MEDICAL LEAVE AND- THANK
AND STRENGTHEN I DON'T PLAN.
PROGR POLICY MAKING WILL HELP
TO ADDRESS EVERYONE YOUR
INVESTMENT IN. AND INTEREST IN
ATTIC WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS AND
LAPLACIAN. AT THE INTERSECTION
OF RACIAL AND GENDER INEQUITY.
APART MOM LET AND HAVING YOUR
CHANGED AND ARE WORK HAS
UNDERVALUED FORTY CENTS ON THE
DOLLAR IT IS SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH
MEEDER DAY NORTHERN FAMILIES
CANNOT AFFORD TO WAIT FOR
CHANGE THANK YOU. FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT I HAD TODAY.
THANK YOU SARAH. WE ARE- NOW
GOING TO HEAR FROM EILEEN RIZZO
WHO SUED HER FORMER EMPLOYER IN
FEDERAL COURT HER CASE WAS
ULTIMATELY LITIGATED BEFORE THE
NINTH US CIRCUIT COURT OF
APPEALS ON THE PAY GAP. IF SHE
FEDERAL AS WELL. OKAY I AM.
WE'LL TRY IT AND- GOOD
AFTERNOON. IT HAPPENED. HELLO
COMMITTEE AND GAS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
OF THE HALF OF IT IS EVERYWHERE
WHO HAS STORIES IT HIGHLIGHTED
SURE SHE FOR ONCE. AB WAS ONE
WE'LL SEE HOW MANY AN AIRLINE
MADE HER HOME. IT OUT OF MY
FATHER WHEN WAS SICK YEARS OLD.
AND RAISED HIM WITH A STRONG
VALUE EDUCATION. AS A YOUNG
GIRL SHE RATED ECONOMY TEACHER.
AND KNOWING THAT OUR
GRANDDAUGHTER THAN LATER DURING.
BUT WHEN HE WAS EIGHT YEARS OLD
HER FATHER REFUSED TO LET HER
CONTINUE HER EDUCATION BECAUSE
MY SCHOOL WAS NOT ROLES.
BEINGNESS WITH TEN YEARS OLD
WHEN HE WAS KIDNAPPED AND
BECAME AN INDIGENOUSLY FOR A
MAN WHO IS CONSIDERED A PIONEER
OTHERWISE LAST. SHE FOR THE
FIRST OF THE THREE CHILDREN
FATHERED BY HER OWNER THE AGE
OF THIRTEEN. LATER SHE SUED FOR
CUSTODY OF HER CHILDREN AND
THERE'S EVEN FIGHT FOR AN
INHERITANCE ON HER ON HER STAFF.
LIKE ME. MAKE CALIFORNIA HOME I
HAD A STRONG MATRIARCHAL BLOOD
THAT ESTIMATING. MY GREAT
GRANDMOTHER'S STORIES THAT I
JUST SHARED. DID NOT MAKE HIS
REMARKS THE DAILY NOTABLE LINES
OF COURAGE AND STRENGTH. THEY
DID IS IN A HOST OF OTHER
CHILDREN GRANDCHILDREN AND
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN COULD AVE
A LIFE OPPORTUNITY AND EQUALITY.
DECADES LATER THEIR DREAMS AND
NOT COME TO COMPLETE FRUITION.
MY PARENTS SACRIFICE THAT I CAN
BE THE FIRST IN MY FAMILY TO
GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE AND
MASTER'S DEGREE OF SCIENCE IN
MATHEMATICS EDUCATION. AND IN
TWO THOUSAND NINE WHEN I
ACCEPTED THE POSITION OF
MATHEMATICS CONSULTANTS AT THE
FRESNO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION I HAVE THIRTEEN YEARS
EXPERIENCE TEACHING MATH AND
PRIVATE PUBLIC CHARTER AND
ONLINE SCHOOLS. I HAVE BEEN A
CURRICULUM DESIGNER FOR
NATIONAL SOFTWARE BASED PROGRAM
ANNOUNCES APARTMENT HEAD ON THE
SCHOOL. AND IT WAS A LEAD
TEACHER FOR THE COURT TO
STUDENTS NEW TO THE COUNTRY. AN
INNER CITY MIDDLE SCHOOL. IT
ALSO FINISH IN MASS DEGREE YOU
TECHNOLOGY. AND WHAT IS YOUR
PLAN I FOUND OUT ABOUT IT HE
DISPARITIES WITHIN NEWLY HIRED
MALE THAT AMOUNTED TO
APPROXIMATELY THIRTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS. I HAD MORE EXPERIENCE
MORE EDUCATION AND MORE
SENIORITY. SO WHEN I WHEN HUMAN
RESOURCES AND WAS INFORMED THAT
MY SALARY WAS BASED EXCLUSIVELY
ON MY PRIOR K. WELL IT SEEMS
LIKE A NEUTRAL POLICY
TRANSACTION. IT IS ASSUMED THAT
WE ALL COME FROM EAGLE PASS.
THAT WE HAD EAGLE HISTORIES AN
EAGLE SANTEE. IF YOU HAVE A
WOMAN LAST WEEK AND HE'S MAKING
LAST. MINUTE PERPETUATING THE
WAGE GAP INTO THE FUTURE. AND
AFTER EIGHT LONG YEARS OF
NAVIGATING THE COURT SYSTEM.
AND SACRIFICING IN WAYS I CAN'T
COMPLETELY EXPLAIN EMOTIONALLY
FINANCIALLY. ON JULY SECOND
TWENTY TWENTY IN THE U. S.
SUPREME COURT DECLINED TO HEAR
A CHALLENGE TO THE NINTH
CIRCUIT UNANIMOUS DECISION IN
MY FAVOR. AND SO THE NINTH
CIRCUIT OPINION STANDS FIRM IT
IS NOW CASE. IN ALL STATES
WITHIN THE NINTH DISTRICT
BETTER USE OF THE PRIOR SALARY
CANNOT JUSTIFY A WAGE
DIFFERENTIAL BETWEEN EMPLOYEES.
MY CASE IS OVER AND THE TORIES
AND DEAN IS ONE I HOPE WE ALL
SHARE. IN MY HOPE THAT PROTECTS
MY THREE DAUGHTERS AND YOURS IN
A WAY THAT WE PROBABLY CAN GET
UNDERSTAND. JUSTICE CONTINUES
BECAUSE EVERY DAY WE PROVED
THAT THE WORLD IS VALUABLE AND
CHANGE IS POSSIBLE. I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE DAY WHEN I
GOOGLE MATHEMATICIAN THAT THE
WEBPAGE. HAS PICTURES OF ME.
AND THAT WE'RE NOT JUST GETTING
GIRLS IN STEM WHERE HEATING
THEM. BECAUSE DOING SCIENCE
TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERING AND
MATHEMATICS. IS WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE LONG. IT IS A PLACE WE
SHOULD FIND OUT. AND IS WE
SHOULD BE. SO WE CAN CLOSE THE
AND IDEAS BUT IT'S TO TAKE TIME
AND EFFORT. UNDER THE OLD
CONVERSATION. AND PURPOSEFUL.
THE LADY THAT WAS TRYING ISSUE
TODAY IT IS ALL RIGHT IT CAN BE
FOR ANY MUCH LONGER. YOU HAVE
MY- TO CONTINUE TO ADD WORK ON
BEHALF OF THE US AND IT WE HAVE
THE ECONOMIC. OF ALL THE- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. RIGHT.
THANK YOUR. WE HAVE OUR OWN
LATINA MATHEMATICIAN ON THE U.
S. DIES SO WITH CRISTINA GARIA
IS ALSO A MATH TEACHER REQUIRE
COMING TO THE LEGISLATURE SO WE
HEAR YOU LOUD AND CLEAR AND
THANK YOU FOR BEING BRAVE
ENOUGH TO TAKE IT TO COURT I'D
ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
WHAT EILEEN EXPERIENCED AS FAR
AS HER PREVIOUS PAY IS
SOMETHING WE TACKLED BY LEVINE
AND FAXES IN A MAN- CARRIED A
BILL A FEW YEARS AGO SO SOME OF
THESE CHANGES HAVE BEEN MADE IN
CALIFORNIA ALTHOUGH.
UNFORTUNATELY AS WE HEARD
THROUGHOUT THIS- IT'S STILL NOT
MAKING THE ADVANCES WOULD LIKE
TO WITH IT SO- BUT THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR STORY BEING
BRAVE ENOUGH TO TAKE IT TO
COURT. WE'RE HERE FROM ONE MORE
ON THIS PANEL THAT WILL OPEN UP
TO QUESTIONS FROM- THE MEMBERS
WHO ARE HERE NEXT IS KAREN
BENCH COURT WE- SHE IS A OR- A
MEMBER OF UNITE HERE LOCAL
THIRTY. AND HER TO TELL HER
STORY. HELLO HI MY NAME IS
KAREN BETTENCOURT I'M TWENTY
EIGHT YEARS OLD AND I LIVE IN
THE SOUTH BAY IN BETWEEN TWENTY
ZERO AND NOT BY MISA. I WORK IN
THE HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY FOR
NEARLY TEN YEARS AND OVER THE
COURSE OF THE TIME I HAVE SEEN
AND BEEN THE SUBJECT OF A
VARIETY OF INJUSTICES
ESPECIALLY ECONOMIC INJUSTICE.
NOT GETTING PAID THE SAME WAGES
AS THE MAN WAS WHAT MADE ME THE
ANGRIEST BECAUSE I KNEW THAT I
WAS WORTH MORE THAN I WAS DOING
THE SAME WORK AS A WHERE.
HERE'S AGO WHEN I WAS WORKING
AT MCDONALDS I WAS PROMOTED
FROM BEING A CASHIER TO A FLOOR
MANAGER. I WAS REALLY EXCITED
BECAUSE I THOUGHT I WAS BEING
RECOGNIZED AND REWARDED FOR MY
HARD WORK AND DEDICATION TO MY
JOB. ASSUME THAT I REALIZED
THAT I WAS THAT WASN'T THE CASE.
THE OTHER FERMENTATIVE INSIDE
ME WAS A YOUNG MAN MAYBE A
COUPLE YEARS OLDER THAN ME. WHO
WAS ALSO PROMOTED FROM CASHIER
TO FLOOR MANAGER A FEW MONTHS
BEFORE ME. WE HAVE THE SAME
RESPONSIBILITIES AND PERFORM
THE SAME WORK BUT SOMEHOW HE
WAS MAKING TWO DOLLARS AND
FIFTY AN HOUR MORE THAN I WAS.
NOW IS ONLY MAKING A DOLLAR. OF
A MOMENT MINIMUM WAGE AND
THAT'S THE WORST. AFTER A FEW
MONTHS I'VE FINALLY ASK MY
MANAGER WHAT I WAS MAKING SO
MUCH LESS. HE WAS. HE TOLD ME
THAT I NEEDED TO TAKE A STEP
DOWN IN ORDER TO MOVE UP. THAT
ANSWER REALLY UPSET ME AND
COMBINED WITH THE WORKLOAD AND
WITH THE OTHER MANAGER ALWAYS
TEASING ME THAT HE WAS MAKING
MORE MONEY THAN ME. FINALLY LET
ME TO QUIT. IT JUST WASN'T
WORTH IT AFTER A QUICK MADONNA
WENT TO WORK AS A ROOM SERVICE
ATTENDANT AT OUR WATER WORK THE
WORKERS REPRESENTED BY UNITE
HERE LOCAL THIRTY DELIVERY
UNION THAT REPRESENTS-
HOSPITALITY WORKERS. THOSE
WORKERS HAVE A UNION CONTRACT
WITH WAGES THAT WERE FAIR FOR
EVERYBODY. ALSO MY BEST FRIEND
WHO IS A LATINA HAD A SIMILAR
EXPERIENCE A FEW YEARS AGO.
MANAGEMENT TO ASK WHAT WAS
GOING ON THEY SAY THEY WILL
LOOK INTO IT. NOTHING EVER CAME
SO SHE LEFT IN DECIDED JUST TO
FOCUS ON HER MASTER'S DEGREE.
TODAY'S SHE'S INTERESTS SOCIAL
WORKER REPRESENTED BY THE
UNION. WHO WORKS FOR THE COUNTY
OF SAN DIEGO. AS FOR ME I NOW
WORK ON THE OTHER AN ORGANIZER
FOR UNITE HERE. WHERE BUILT UP
ENOUGH LIKE MYSELF TO ENSURE
THAT THEY HAVE A FAIR AND
EQUITABLE WORKPLACES. WITH GOOD
BAIT MAKING THE SAME MONEY AND
HAVING THE SAME BENEFITS OTHER
MY COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. I MEAN OPEN IT UP NOW TO
OUR PANEL LEGISLATORS IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- FROM THAT FIRST PANEL
ON JUST THE OVERALL PAY GAP.
BUT SINCE EILEEN IS STILL ON
THE- ON ON THE SCREEN I WANT TO
TELL YOU HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
THAT YOU SHARED YOUR GREAT
GRANDMOTHER STORY. AND IT'S
CLEAR THAT YOU ARE GET OUT JUST
LIKE SHE WAS AND I SALUTE YOU
FOR THAT THAT'S SO IMPORTANT I
LOVE THAT AND I LOVE THAT WE
HAVE HERE AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ MENTIONED WE HAVE OUR
OWN MATH MATH MATHEMATICIAN BUT
WE ALL GOT GO TO WHEN WE HAVE
THESE ISSUES WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT STEM SAME AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOOSE A THREE OF US. WHO
IS OUR OTHERS THEM BABY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR SHARING THAT
STORY AND IF I MAY CAMERON. WHO
JUST SPOKE. KAREN WOULD WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT WHAT YOU THE
FACT YOU LEFT THE JOB DO YOU
KNOW IF ANY OF THE- OTHER
LATINOS WHO COME AFTER YOU HAVE
THINGS CHANGED OR IS IT STILL
THE SAME AT MCDONALD'S. COME UP
TO THE MICROPHONE BECAUSE IF
NOT IT'S AND FORTUNATELY WERE
VIRTUAL ALSO. I BELIEVE
EVERYTHING SAY THE SAME I LOST
CONTACT WITH A LOT OF ROOM SO.
AS FAR AS I KNOW. THE CHANGE.
AT NIGHT I THOUGHT THAT WAS
GOING TO BE YOUR ANSWER AND I'M
VERY SORRY TO HEAR THAT BUT I
WANTED IT SAID SO THAT NOT JUST
MCDONALD'S BUT ALL OF THE OTHER
EMPLOYERS RECOGNIZE THAT.
PEOPLE ARE WATCHING PEOPLE
PEOPLE KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING.
AND WE DO WANT TO SEE A CHANGE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
MANAGER KAREN AS LONG AS YOU'RE
HERE IF I'M SORRY TO PUT YOU ON
THE SPOT I SHOULD. PROBABLY
WARN SHOULD ASK THIS QUESTION
BUT SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
LEADING A PAY GAP THERE ARE THE
TRADITIONAL- THOUGHTS IF YOU'RE
IN THE SAME JOB AND YOU MAKE IT
DIFFERENT AMOUNT LIKE YOU WERE
YOU WERE DESCRIBING. ALSO WHAT
I LEAN WITH DESCRIBING- HAVING
THE SAME RESPONSIBILITIES THE
SAME BACKGROUND AND YET YOU'RE
MAKING LESS THAN YOUR WHITE
MALE COUNTERPART. BUT WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL ISSUES THAT I
HOPEFULLY I'M NOT CATCHING UP
GARDEN IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE
ANSWERS OKAY TOO BUT- WE HAVE.
WE HAVE THAT'S THE TRADITIONAL
PAY GAP YOU'RE IN THE SAME JOB
IN NOT MAKING THE SAME EASY TO
PROVE IN COURT BUT WE HAVE A
COMPOUNDED PROBLEM WITH- JOBS
THAT ARE TRADITIONALLY WOMEN
HELP LET ME KNOW HEALTH. AND I
WOULD THINK IN FACT IN HOTELS
FROM AT LEAST PAST EXPERIENCES-
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN FOR
EXAMPLE A HOTEL HOUSEKEEPER IN
A BILL MA'AM RIGHT WELL BILL
PERSON BUT SO OFTEN MEN HOTEL
HOUSEKEEPERS TEND TO BE LEVINE
AS- OVERWHELMINGLY ARE WOMEN
WHO ARE- IMMIGRANTS AND THEN. A
LOT OF THE- BILL BOYS. ARE
WHITE MEN. CAN YOU SPEAK TO THE
DIFFERENCE IN WHAT HAPPENS WITH
LIKE FOR EXAMPLE GETTING TIPS
OR THEIR CONTRACT IS THERE A
DIFFERENCE IN HOW WE VALUE
THESE JOBS ONE ONE BEING DONE
BY A LEVINE AND ONE GET BE DONE.
ONE BY ONE MA'AM. PREDOMINANT I
KNOW. A MY GET UP FROM. WHO
FELLOW AND THAT'S GREAT BUT- I
PERSONALLY I NEVER A LATINA. OR
O. WOMAN THAT IT'S A BILL
PERCENT. AT ALWAYS AND IT'S
RIGHT AWAY BUT THE TIPS ARE
MAKES THEM. YOU KNOW EARNED FOR-
I GUESS OR I'M ASSUMING THAT
BECAUSE- AS A HOUSEKEEPER THIS
IS JUST REVISION OF THE WOMEN
BUILD UP JOB. AND I DON'T THINK
IT'S FAIR IT'S THEY THEY MADE-
WITH THE UNION CONTRACT TO MAKE-
GOOD MONEY BUT I BELIEVE THAT.
THAT IS NOT ENOUGH AND YOU KNOW
AT THE MOMENT THEY MAKE MINIMUM
WAGE BUT THE TIPS ARE WHAT MAKE
THEM MAKE MORE- THAT. THANK YOU
IT'S JUST ONE OF THE THINGS SO
OFTEN- ESPECIALLY A JOBS HELD
BY LATINOS A IN THIS IS WHY WE
START THE ON SCENE MEDINA AND
IS TO- GO UNSEEN RIGHT A LOT OF
TIMES IF YOU STAY AT A HOTEL WE
DON'T NECESSARILY SEE OUR HOTEL
HOUSEKEEPER. AND WE FORGET THAT
MAYBE WE SHOULD TAKE THEM TO
WHERE WE SEE THE BELLBOY WE
FEEL GUILTY AND SO YOU KNOW WE
IMMEDIATELY TOOK THEM- AND SO
IT'S AS SOMETIMES JUST THE LINE
OF WORK IN WHO HAS
TRADITIONALLY HELD IT AND HOW
WE TREAT THEM SO. THANK YOU
THOUGH THANK YOU FOR TELLING
YOUR EXPERIENCE IN THE WIDE
VARIETY OF FIELDS. ARE THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS IF NOT
WE'LL MOVE TO OUR SECOND PANEL
OF. MISTER JONES SAWYER PLEASE.
DID THAT WORK ALL RIGHT- I'M
FROM LOS ANGELES- REPRESENTS
SOUTH LOS ANGELES AND PROBABLY
MORE IMPORTANT I WORK FOR THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES FOR ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE YEARS IN AN
APARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES. AND
FOR DECADES- ESPECIALLY IN THE
CUSTODIAL GROUP WEARS MOSTLY
LATINOS. THE ONES THAT WORKED
IN THE EVENING NOT ONLY WERE
THEIR THEIR WAGES KIND OF
SUPPRESSED. I RECALL THERE WAS
THIS KIND OF ENVIRONMENTAL.
STRUGGLE THAT WAS GOING ON WE
FOUND OUT THERE WERE MALE
SUPERVISORS THAT IF A WOMAN
SPOKE UP ABOUT THEIR WORK HOURS
INJUSTICES BEING FORCED TO DO
THINGS. SOMETIMES SEXUAL- IT IT
CREATED AN ATMOSPHERE WHERE NO
ONE SPOKE UP. AND THAT ALSO
COULD CREATE A CHASM IN IN THE
WORKPLACE AND THERE WERE MALES-
AND WERE MALE ALLIES THAT WHEN
IT TO HELP. BUT THEY DIDN'T
KNOW WHAT TO DO- THANK GOD FOR.
THE ME TOO MOVEMENT BECAUSE NOW
WE'RE WE'RE BEING TAUGHT YOUR
MAIL ALLY. THIS PRESS THE
MEMBERS ARE ON THIS COMMITTEE
ARE BEING TAUGHT ON HOW WE CAN
HELP. ELIMINATE THAT DEBT
HOSTILE WORK ENVIRONMENT AND
THIS MAY BE POOR MAYBE FOR
SARAH CRAWFORD THE LAWYER. BUT
HOW CAN WE BE MALE ALLIES HELP.
IN THIS EFFORT BECAUSE WHEN
SOMEONE COMES TO ME. AND- BACK
IN THE DAY THEY CAME TO ME AND
SAID THEY WERE BEING OPPRESSED
OR DEPARTMENT WAS OF A SEXUAL
NATURE. I DON'T HAVE THE TOOLS
NOT KNOWING WHAT TO DO I DO NOW
I KNOW EXACTLY WHAT TO DO NOW.
AND SO I THINK WE NEED TO GET
OUR MALE ALLIES- INVOLVE IN
THIS FOR LATINOS IN THE WAY
THAT PROBABLY HAS NEVER BEEN
DONE BEFORE. BECAUSE I BELIEVE
IF ALL BOATS RISE DO WE ALL
RIGHT YOU JUST CAN'T LEAVE
ANYBODY BEHIND. THANK YOU I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE IS ARE YOU
STILL ON THE PHONE IF YOU CAN
ADDRESS WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
TACTICS THAT MEN MALE ALLIES
CAN USE TO HELP WITH KIND OF
THESE GENDER DISPARITIES. SHE'S
ON THE LINE I AM HERE.
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN HEAR ME- YES
WE CAMP. HE DID AN EXCELLENT
QUESTION AND EXACTLY THE KIND
OF QUESTION THAT WE LOVE HEAR
YOU KNOW HOW CAN MEN BE BETTER
ANALYZE. AND THERE IS A BIG MAN
OKAY NAY YOU BUY. READINGS AND
THEN- WHO ARE. BEING ACTIVE- HE
ACTIVE PEOPLE THAT ARE BUYING
HERE HAVE TO MEDIA. IRAQ
ANYTHING THEN IT. TO SPEAK OUT
I WILL THEY SEE THEM GOING ON
THAT IS NOT RIGHT EVEN THAT MY
ISSUE AN IDENTITY. WORKING IN A
COUNTRY ASSEMBLY TRAIN AND- MAN
TO EVER ACTING- WHETHER
MANAGERS OR COLLEAGUES OR THIRD
PARTIES WHETHER CUSTOMERS OR
CLIENTS- IT YEAH EVEN IF I DID
ANYTHING MOVEMENT WE ARE STILL
BEING AND RECORD NUMBERS OF
COMPLAINTS THAT RACK MEN'S. IN
AND THEN CALIFORNIA HAD MADE
GOOD PROGRESS YOU- DO CAN PASS
LAWS TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
WOMEN TO COME FORWARD WITH
COMPLAINTS OF HARASSMENT- TO
GET RELIEF WHEN THEY FACE
HARASSMENT- IT CERTAINLY THERE
IS MUCH WORK TO BE DONE AND I
THINK A GREAT FIRST STEP WILL
BE INVOLVING MEN WERE ACTIVELY
AND BEING OUTLINED. ITS PLAN
RECOMMENDED- THANK YOU. QUITE
FRANKLY WE ARE THE PROBLEM MAN
NO MATTER WHAT COLOR NOT JUST
WHITE MEN SO WE NEED TO BE
ACTIVE IN THE SOLUTION. THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THAT UP YOU
KNOW- ARE COMMITTEE IN
PARTICULAR AND- WE HIGH LIKE
THIS EVERY TIME WE HAVE TRIED
SPECIFICALLY TO ENSURE. THAT
THE DISCUSSION IS CENTERED
AROUND THE **** SO FOR MOST OF
OUR IMPACT ALL OF OUR HEARINGS-
THE PRIMARY OF FOLKS WHO SPEAK
ARE LATINOS IF WE CAN'T FIND A
LEVINE IN THE FIELD OR ARE
THERE OTHER- FOLKS WHO ARE
EXPERTS WE EXTEND THAT TO WOMEN
FIRST- AND WE HAVE YET TO HAVE
A MALE. EVEN TESTIFY AT ONE OF
OUR COMMITTEES- LET- LET ME
KNOW. IF WE REALLY HAVE TRIED
TO DO IT INTENTIONALLY. BUT
PERHAPS FOR A FUTURE HEARING WE
SHOULD HAVE A PANEL MINNETONKA
ABOUT HOW- AND NON LATINO WOMEN
IN TALK ABOUT ALLEGATIONS AND
WHAT CAN BE DONE- I THINK
YOU'RE BRINGING UP A GOOD POINT
WHERE WE'RE TRYING TO
CONSTANTLY- RELY ON OURSELVES
AND I THINK THAT. THERE'S A
REASON WORK WE'RE DOING THAT
HIGHLIGHTING BECAUSE THERE ARE
EXPERTS IN THE FIELD THAT ARE
LIKE YOU KNOW WE WANT A HIGH
LIKE THAT BUT- THAT'S A REALLY
GOOD POINT AND I THINK WE'LL
WE'LL TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION FOR MAYBE OUR
NEXT HEARING IS. IS THINK ABOUT
HOW- THE STRATEGIES ARE BEING
USED BY NON LATINOS TO HELP.
PULL UP LATINAS WHO ARE
TRADITIONALLY INCIDENT WORKS
THANK YOU READY FOR THAT.
MISTER JONES SAWYER. M. AS WE
GET CASUAL EACH OTHER THEN IT'S
HARD. REMEMBER WHAT CALL EACH
OTHER. WITHOUT WE'RE GOING TO
GO HEAD TO MOVE ON TO OUR
SECOND PANEL WERE RIGHT ON TIME
WHICH IS GREAT- AND I'M REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT OUR NEXT PANELIST
IS SHE- PHONE OR VIDEO. VIDEO
WE ARE CALIFORNIA LABOR
COMMISSIONER I HAVE KNOWN FOR
YEARS BECAUSE WE WORK HERE IN
SAN DIEGO PREVIOUSLY WHEN WE-
HAD DIFFERENT POSITIONS- BUT IT
IS GREAT TO HAVE A LATINA AS
THE- CALIFORNIA LABOR
COMMISSIONER. TO TALK ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA WILL PAY I
PROTECTIONS FOR WORKERS
ENFORCEMENT LATELY AYE GARCIA
OUR- LAFFOON. YOU SO MUCH MADAM
CHAIR CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE
CAN WONDERFUL THANK YOU IT IS
MY HONOR TO JOIN THIS
CONVERSATION AND I'M GOING TO
PROVIDE SOME OF THE SPECIFIC
INFORMATION ABOUT CLEAN DATA-
THAT IS AVAILABLE THROUGH OUR
OFFICE BUT IN GENERAL I JUST
WANT TO STAND IN SOLIDARITY AS
A FIRST GENERATION OF MEXICAN
AND CHICANA WOMEN IN THIS
COUNTRY- WITH THE COMMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN EXPRESSED THANK YOU
SO MUCH ADRIN- FOR THE
CONTRIBUTIONS YOU MADE AND I
ECHO OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
APPRECIATION FOR YOU- INVOKING
YOUR GREAT-GRANDMOTHER'S OF
SPIRIT AND YOUR ANCESTORS. INTO
THIS CONVERSATION I THINK IT IS
SO IMPORTANT FOR US TO EXAMINE
AT ALL LEVELS IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR AND PUBLIC SECTOR I KNOW
AS- I BELIEVE I AM THE FIRST
LATINA LABOR COMMISSIONER IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I'M
ALSO THE FIRST- COMPLETELY
SATISH FLUENT SPANISH SPEAKER
OF SO I ALSO APPRECIATE THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN'S ARREST SORRY
THIS IS RACIST COMMENTS ABOUT
US SPEAKING IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES AND LOOKING STUDENTS
OUR COMMUNITIES. THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE IS THE
CHIEF WAGE ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HOWEVER WE ALL KNOW THAT SADLY
THESE PROTECTIONS ALTHOUGH
INCREDIBLY FALL HARD FOUGHT BY
COMMUNITY LEADERS SOME OF THEM
ON THIS PANEL YU WILL HEAR
FROM TODAY AND FROM YOU FEARS
LEADERS BEFORE US- WHO HAVE
BEEN VERY BOLD IN LEADERSHIP IN
RESPONDING TO THE HARMS WE KNOW
HAPPENING IN THESE WORKPLACES
NONETHELESS THESE LAWS LIMITING
THE BILL AND I AGREE TOWER. IS
WORKERS DO NOT UNDERSTAND THEIR
RIGHTS THEN THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO EXERCISE. THEM AND THE HE
OKAY PROTECT ACT OF BILLS RIGHT
PROVIDE UNDER THE P. ARE NOT
JUST. WITH TO OUR AT AVAILABLE.
AT MINIMAL WAGE AND ALL. AND
MEAL AND REST AND THE OTHER IS
AS THE OF MADAM CHAIR HAS
ALREADY IDENTIFIED AND- I HAVE
FOUND IN MY TWO YEARS OF
SERVICE INTERNALLY THAT WE ARE
NOT DOING ENOUGH AND ONE OF MY
PRIMARY OBJECTIVE IS TO BREAK
DOWN THESE WALLS AND BARRIERS
GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO COME OUT.
OF THESE BUILDINGS AND WE NEED
TO MEET TO THE COMMUNITY WHERE
ARE WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THE
INSTITUTIONAL I'M SORRY
INTERGENERATIONAL TRAUMA THAT
WE HEARD EILEEN SPEAKING ABOUT
WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THE
TRAUMAS THAT WE HEARD THE
SISTER- WOULD WORK AT
MCDONALD'S. ABOUT TO MANY OF
THE WORKERS IN THE STATE HAVE
NO FAITH IN OUR OPERATION OF
THESE BASIC PROTECTIONS IN US
AS GOVERNMENT IS THERE ARE
EMPLOYMENT. SO WE NEED TO BUILD
A PATHWAY TO HEALING AB ONE OF
THE THINGS I AM DOING IS I
IMPLEMENTED A TRAUMA INFORMED
INITIATIVE WE NEED TO BECOME
TRAUMA INFORMED WE CANNOT
CONTINUE TO BE TRANSACTIONAL
WITH THESE MATTERS OF LAW AND
ENFORCEMENT. BECAUSE WE ARE
FURTHER HARMONY OUR COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR OUR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES ARE SINGLE MOMS ARE
LGBT ARTS YOU ARE WORKERS WITH
FUNCTIONAL AND ACCESS NEEDS
ANALYSTS ALSO ON AND ON AND ON.
SO WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND AS THE
PANEL HAS OR A SORRY AS THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S ALREADY
RECOGNIZED WE DO NOT ALL START
FROM THE SAME PLACE AND WE ALL
KERRY VARIOUS. EXPERIENCES IN
THIS COUNTRY AND IN WERE THAT
WE BRING. ALAMEDA A COUNTRY
THAT HAS A HISTORY US. AND
LABOUR. WHEN CANNOT ACT AS IF
WE HAVE THE SAME STAR POINT. SO
WHAT. SHARE DAY. BACK IN-
DISCERNING- BUT ANOTHER LESS.
WE WERE WE WERE ASKED TO SHARE
OF THOSE. SO IN THE LAST THREE.
WE HAVE RECEIVED ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EPA CLAIMS-
AND ETA HAS NOTED WAS RECENTLY
EXTENDED BY GOVERNOR BROWN'S.
TO INCLUDE RACE AND ETHNICITY.
AND SO FIFTY SIX OF THE SLAIN
HAVE BEEN ACCESS FOR
INVESTIGATING SO THAT'S ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY OF THEM.
OF THOSE THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY CLAIMS WE HAVE ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE OF THEM
THAT ARE ACTIVE. TWO HUNDRED
AND SIX OF THEM HAVE BEEN
CLOSED 67% OF THEM HAVE BEEN
CLOSED BECAUSE WORKERS HAVE
WITHDRAWN THEIR CLEAN OR
ABANDON THEIR CLAIMS I ASKED A
LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS
CLASSIFICATION WHAT DOES IT
MEAN WHEN A WORKING ABANDONS OR
A WORKER- AT. WITH LAWCENTER
CLEAN AND A LOT OF IT IS FORMAL
WITHDRAWAL BUT IF YOU HAVE
ADDED IS WHEN WORKERS SPONSORED
AND OUR AGENCY DOES WORK A LOT
WE DIDN'T MAKE A LOT OF CALLS
AND TRYING TO GET EMAILS
AVAILABLE IF FOLKS ARE
REPRESENTATIVES SOMETIMES AND
WE HAVE A BETTER CHANCE OF
GETTING A HOLD OF THEM. HELLO
I'M NOT SURPRISED BY THESE
NUMBERS GET A WHAT I JUST SAID
KNOWLEDGE IN MY OPENING
COMMENTS AND WE KNOW FROM THE
TESTIMONY THAT WE HEARD THAT
THESE TWO WOMEN TODAY ARE
REPRESENTATIVE UNFORTUNATELY A
HUNDRED AND THOUSANDS MILLIONS
OF WORKERS SO THIS CLEARLY RE
ITERATES THE NEED FOR US TO
WARRANT THAT ESTABLISH AN
ADDITIONAL PROTECTIONS. WE HAVE
TO CHANGE THE WAY WE ENGAGE
WITH OUR COMMUNITY A PROGRAM I
LOST IN AUGUST OF TWENTY TWENTY
IS A WORKPLACE RIGHTS
AMBASSADORS PROJECT THIS IS A
TRAUMA INFORMED STRATEGY
INITIATIVE WHERE WE ARE
REACHING OUT WAY FROM UNITY
PARTNERS LIKE THE EAST VALLEY
WOMAN CENTER. LIKE THE BLACK
WORKER CENTER LAGGY THIS GONNA
SEEN US WHO ARE TRUSTED
COMMUNITY LEADERS WHO SO MANY
TRAUMATIZED WORKERS WILL NOT
COME FROM GOVERNMENTS BUT THEY
WILL GO TO THESE COMMUNITY
LEADERS AND WE ARE LOOKING TO
BUILD A. LONG LAST YEAR
INSTITUTIONAL RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE LABOR COME. OFFICE
AND THESE KIND OF PARTNERS SO
THAT WHEN. THEY ARE YOU V.
VICTOR AS THEY ARE HELD MY- AND
FATHERS. THROUGH IT SYSTEM OR
NOT CARE SYSTEM. AND THEY HEAR
ABOUT ISSUES THAT WE- IT
DOESN'T GET PUSHED ASIDE BUT
THAT ACTUALLY IS THE FLAG FOR
THEM AND SAY HI I KNOW WHERE I
COULD GO GET HELP WITH THIS
INDIVIDUAL AND FOR HIS AMILY.
SO WE NEED TO DO A LOT MORE
ANOTHER INITIATIVE WE HAVE IS
EACH AND EVERY CALIFORNIAN
CAMPAIGN THIS IS AN OUTREACH
CAMPAIGN THAT WE ALSO LAUNCHED
LAST YEAR IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
PANDEMIC. AND OUR PRIORITY TO
CONTACT IN THIS CAMPAIGN
ARSANIS VIPERS WE HAVE OPENED-
COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE TV
NETWORKS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE OPEN COMMUNICATION WITH
HOUSING ORGANIZATIONS AGAIN FOR
THIS REALITY THAT YOU CANNOT
COMPARTMENTALIZE THIS ISSUE I
THINK WE HAVE ALL SEEN. IN THE
PAST JANET HOW THE REALITIES OF
THE WORKPLACE ARE MATTERS OF
SOCIAL L. B. AND AFFECT
EVERYBODY SO I LOOK VERY MUCH
FORWARD TO WORKING. WITH THIS
COMMITTEE AND I WOULD LOVE TO
FOLLOW UP WITH I BELIEVE A
WITNESS DAY WAS CAMERON-
BECAUSE WHAT SHE REPORTED BE
DONALD- IS DISTURBING AS WITH
ANY EMPLOYER WHO ENGAGE IN SUCH
PRACTICES AND I KNOW IN THE
JANITORIAL INDUSTRY I'VE HEARD
FROM WOMEN I KNOW. AGDISTIS
HOWEVER FOR WOMEN SO MOST OF IT
ET CLEAN THAT WE HAVE RECEIVED
THEY ARE JUST. ACROSS ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES.
AND THE CONCENTRATION
GEOGRAPHICALLY. IS LAW ROGER
COUNTY SO THE TOP FOR FAMILIES
ARE LAWSUIT. SACRAMENTO SAN
DIEGO. OR COUNTY ALTHOUGH THEY
DID NOT OF. ARE RELATIVE LOW
COMPARED TO YOU TO THE OF
COUNTY- THE INDUSTRY CONSTANT.
ALL IT IS TOO HARD DIFFERENT
INDUSTRY ROBERT. IN THE- THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY WE RECEIVE. MOST
OF THE THAT ARE IN AFTER
INVESTIGATION OUR HIGH YOUR AND
IMPLEMENTS IT IS IN THE MEDICAL
FOR. IT IS IN A LEGAL.
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT REPRESENTATION FROM
THE SECURITY OFFICER- FIELD AND
SO MY POINTS OF REFERENCE IN
THE WITNESSES TESTIMONY IS
THERE ARE TOO MANY WOMEN
EMPLOYED IN LOW WAGE
INDUSTRIES- WHO THIS IS FAR
BEYOND. ANYTHING THAT THEY- OF
ALL WHAT SHE DOES- COULD COST
CALL UNDER Y OF OUR EXISTING
PAY ACT SO I VERY MUCH. LOVE TO
WORK WITH EVERYBODY TO HELP TO
REACH MORE INDIVIDUALS AND MAKE
THIS INFORMATION. AVAILABLE
THANK YOU MANAGER. THANK YOU-
COMMISSIONER I ALSO WOULD BE
REMISS WHY YOU HAVE HERE RIGHT
IT DOES NOT GO UNNOTICED I
THINK ON THIS BOARD THE NUMBER
OF WAGE CLAIM- IMAGE
CLASSIFICATION SUITS BEING AS-
BEING SETTLED OUT OF YOUR
OFFICE RECENTLY SO. AND
ACTIVISTS LABOR COMMISSIONER
SOMETHING WE'VE ALWAYS DREAMED
OF IN- IT'S GREAT TO HAVE YOU
THERE THAT'S ALL AT LEAST HI OF
SPEAK FOR MYSELF ON THAT I'VE
ALWAYS DREAMED OF- SO IT'S
GREAT TO HAVE YOU THERE IN
TACKLING THIS WITH US BECAUSE I
THINK YOU'RE RIGHT YOU KNOW- SO
MANY OF OUR LEVINE AS DON'T
EVEN. KNOW THIS LOG THIS AND-
HOW WE GET THEM COMFORTABLE
WITH EXERCISING THEIR RIGHTS IS
A BIG QUESTION I'M SURE WE'LL
HAVE QUESTIONS FOR YOU BUT
WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
REST OF THE PANEL THEN COME
BACK- NEXT WE HAVE HOLLY
MARTINEZ FROM THE COMMISSION ON
THE STATUS. OF WOMEN AND GIRLS.
SHE IS ALSO A VIRTUAL. GOOD
AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR ME OK.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH
THAT I'VE ALREADY IS THE
INTERIM EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE COLONY COMMISSION ON THE
STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS ON
DECEMBER CHAIRMAN AND ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING CONDITIONS TO CO
SPONSOR IS HEARING ADDRESS
IDEOLOGY THAT THE COMMISSION
HAS PURSUED AFTER NEARLY THREE
YEARS NOW AND THE WAGE GAP FOR
WOMEN PARTICULARLY WOMEN OF
COLOR I'M NOT CHIU FORMER
COMMISSIONER AT THE CENTER
HANNAH JACKSON WHO PASSED A
PAIR OF HATE THAT HEALTHCARE HE
ACTS WHEN ASIANS THOMAS LAWSON
ABOUT THE GENDER PAY EQUITY. IN
TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN THE
COMMISSION WAS PASSED IN THE
CANADIAN CALIFORNIA PAY EQUITY
TASK FORCE WHICH TOOK A HARD
LOOK AT LEAST CHAPLAIN FROM
EAGLE SUBSTANTIAL RESOURCE
LIBRARY RECOMMENDATIONS IF YOU
CONTINUE TO IMPLEMENTING THE
EQUAL PAY PROGRAMS AND IN
COLLABORATION WITH FIRST THE
FIRST PARTNER WHO HAS AN
INCREDIBLE. TEAM FOR THIS ISSUE.
EVERY THE COMMISSION HONORS
YEAR TO THE GO PAID EVERY. HOW
LONG IS THE FOLLOWING YEAR. HE
SAID APPROVAL WHEN THE TO WORK
IN CASH I TO WHAT I'M EMAIL ME
THAT. YEAR LYCAENID CONSIDER
COME LAST. WE'RE LUCKY ABOUT
ISSUE AND FABRIC OF. WERE FOR A
SEVENTY MILE ADDRESS. AT LEAST
IN THIS SPACE THAT MAY IS THE
CONCERNED WITH THE- THAT IS
FOR. PAID OUT IN THE COMPOUND
IS AT ALL. THERAPY AND THE
ROUTINE VALUE IN OTHER WORDS
YOU CALIFORNIA LISTING. THE IS
A OKAY THAT IS PURELY BY NOT
THIRTY YEARS. IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE THE OF THE PAGES
FIFTY CENTS FOR DOLLAR PAID TO
WHITE WINE. AT TODAY THE IRISH
IS ONLY SEVENTH TO THE- IN REAL
TERMS THIS MEANS THAT HE GOT
REALLY SEEN IT IS NEAR. JUST
OVER PENNY EVERY IRAQI CITIZEN
EIGHTY. IT IS UNACCEPTABLE THAT
DO NOT TWENTY ONE IS AGE LIMIT
SHOULD FACE SINGLE. WAY AFTER
WOMEN. WELL THE COMMISSION
OFFERS THE FIRST WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE RECOGNIZE. WORKPLACE
ALSO NEED TO. BE IT IS TRAINING
THE OFF OFFERED FOR. FACING TO
TAKE A EQUAL PAY PLAN ASK
BUSINESS TO YOU AN- ANNUAL
COMPANY CENTER HANDLE IS
READING HIRING AND PROMOTIONAL
PRACTICES THESE TREES BIAS AND
BARRIERS. AND IDENTIFY AND
IMPROVE BEST. PRACTICES TO
ELIMINATE EIGHT AT. WE'RE ALSO
THINKING- THE POLICY MAY AND IS
OFTEN. RESEARCHERS YOU KNOW.
HOW WOMAN FOR. THERE IS AN
UNDERSTANDABLE DESIRE TO
GREENHAWK TO AGREE ON ANYTHING
S. ONE BE FIXED WATER AND- IT
WAS KIND OF SITTING GAS AND
INEQUALITY AT YOU SEE THERE'S
NO SINGLE REFORM THAT CAN
REVERSE EXACTLY WHAT DECADES.
OF HARMFUL STRUCTURAL BIAS.
BOTH LOCAL REFORMS AND THERE HE
NOW. THIS HAS LEGISLATIVE
SESSION AND COMMISSION IS A
PART OF. AND JUST GONZALEZ IS
EVEN OF TWENTY. WHICH WOULD
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF ENGLAND.
WORKERS RECEIVE ALL IN THE
STATE'SHE FAMILY. TO THE
BOTTOM OF THAT ANYMORE OR CARE
FOR A. SICK LOVELL AND- WHEN IT
TO LIMITS. SECURITY MITCHELL.
TO BE AN ADDED FOR APOLLO. THAT
THAT WOMEN AS WORKERS INTERESTS
SERVICE THAT IS PREDICTABLE AND
FLEXIBLE SCHEDULING. ACCESS TO
THE SICK LEAVE AND CHILDCARE
STRENGTHENING PROTECTIONS
AGAINST EMPLOYER RETALIATION
FOR WORKERS ASSERT THEIR RIGHTS
AND OF COURSE ACCESS TO LIVING
WAGE. WE RECOGNIZE THE PUNISHER
PAY EQUITY MUST MOVE BEYOND
PROHIBITING PAY DISCRIMINATION
THE UPCOMING LEGISLATIVE CYCLE
WE HOPE TO PARTNER WITH MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE THE
LEGISLATION AND HONOR STUDENT
HAS MEASURES RELATED TO REQUIRE
EVERY OPPORTUNITY TRANSPARENCY
WHEN IT COMES TO JOB POSTINGS
AND FILLING CORPORATE BOARD
SEATS. BY INSURING THAT LAWYERS
TO DISCLOSE COMPENSATION AND
BENEFITS OF THE JOB DUTIES
WOMEN CAN HAVE A. BETTER SENSE
OF THEIR NEGOTIATING POWER. IN
ADDITION WILL BE BACK TO WORK
WE IS AN OPENING AFTER.
OPPORTUNITY TO THE PUBLIC CAN'T
INSURE A PATH LEADING SERVICE
FOR THOSE WERE QUALIFIED BUT
NOT CONNECTED. THE WAIT TIME IS
LARGELY BECAUSE INSTRUCTIONAL
LICENSE REDUCES LISTING IS
EXPECTED EARNINGS INCLUDING
THAT AERATION OF ARCANE
OCCUPATIONS AND INDUSTRIES
ACCORDING TO THE WASHINGTON
CENTER FOR EQUITABLE GROWTH.
HELLO THERE IN THE FOR OF
OCCUPATIONAL SEGREGATION UNDER
VALUED LEADERSHIP BIAS AND
GLARINGLY UNEQUAL PAY FOR LABOR
LOOKING AHEAD OF FAR TOO OFTEN
COME LAST. LEADERS IN THE US
ARE PAID ON AVERAGE 45% LESS
THAN WHITE MEN AND 30% LESS
THAN WHITE WOMEN. ACCORDING TO
THE DATE OF THE NATIONAL
PARTNERSHIP ON WITHIN FAMILIES
AND LEADERS U. S. THE PAGE APP
THE WAIT APPLE CAUSATIVES
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND NINETY
DOLLARS EACH YEAR. THAT ADDED
UP TO ONE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS WE'RE DELIGHTED IN.
LOSSES OVER THE COURSE OF HER
CAREER. LOWER EARLY ALSO
BELIEVE LET YOU KNOW WORKERS
FAMILIES HALF YOU RESEARCH. TO
MEET AT A AND HAVE TO IN A-
ACCORDING TO THE INSTITUTE FOR
WOMEN POLICY THREE. ASSISTANTS
AND HAD NOT NEXT HOUSEHOLD
EXPERIENCE LOTS. OF EAGER. THE
AT OUR SPECIAL HONORED TO HELP.
HAS AND EAGLE LAWSUIT HE HAD A
LOWEST INDUSTRY COVERAGE ANY
RELATION OR AT GROUP AND LOWEST
LEVEL HAD AN ADVOCATE OFF.
LEADERS ARE NOT PROJECTED TO
REACH PERRY AND YOUR THE TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR WE CANNOT
WAIT ANOTHER TWO HUNDRED YEARS
ON THE SEVEN MILLION OF
CALIFORNIA'S WORKERS TO REACH
QUALITY. I THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME HERE TODAY I ENCOURAGE
EVERYONE TO TERRORIZE. WITH US
YOU DON'T HAVE TO LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH ALL OF YOU TO
LIVE LATINO VOICES TOGETHER AND
MAKE SURE THAT QUALITY AND
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE CITY HAS
COME FIRST AND LAST. THANK YOU
HOLLY- WE'LL MOVE ON NOW TO
JESSICA STENDER- SHE'S AN
ATTORNEY WITH EQUAL RIGHTS HAVE
A KIDS WORKS WITH US CLOSELY ON
LEGISLATION THE CAPITAL. SHE'S
ALSO VIRTUALLY. JESSICA YES CAN
YOU HEAR ME. THE NEW WE CAN
AREA. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PROVIDE TESTIMONY
HOW ADVOCATES WE ARE NATIONAL
NONPROFIT LEGAL ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO PROTECTING AND
EXPANDING ECONOMIC EDUCATIONAL
ACCESS OPPORTUNITIES FOR WOMEN
AND GIRLS AND PEOPLE ARE LIKE
GENERATED HE'S AND HE'S READY
TO ASSURING THAT OUR QUALITY
AND ADVANCING AND OUT OF THE
THREE IS AT EVEN IN. TODAY I
HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE WE
DISCRIMINATION AND WORKING TO
CLOSE THE WEEK AT WE'VE ALREADY
HEARD ABOUT THE STAGGERING%
NUMBERS THAT LEADING
UNIVERSITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND ONE OF THE WORST WE'VE
GOTTEN BACK HERE IN OUR STATE
A. ARE THE THESIS ANGELA IN
SECURITY PRIOR TO THE GOLDEN
NINETEEN HEADACHE AND IT WAS
FURTHER EXACERBATED WE ALL KNOW
BY DEMANDING RESULTING IN A
CRISIS. SO NO THAT'S LONG HAUL
HE RESPONDS OTHER CRITICAL TO
ADDRESSES WHERE YOU GOT THE
FINAL OUT UNITS AND BREAK THE
CITADEL WEALTH DISPARITIES THAT
CONTINUE TO HOLD AND THEIR
FAMILIES BACK WE TALKED SOME
ABOUT IMPORTANT SEPTIC
CALIFORNIA SEEKING TO ADDRESS
THE WAGE GAP- MANY ARE LAWS OF
CERTAIN THE BLUEPRINT FOR OTHER
STATES TO FOLLOW AND WHILE THE
BURDEN TRACTION HAVE LED TO
SOME REMAIN AS WE DISCUSS ANY
PERSISTENCE ANNA HARM OF THE
WEEK AFTER LOOKING AT REALLY
GETTING AND- CONTINUED AND MORE
RIGOROUS POLICY CHANGE TO DO
BETTER ADDRESSING CONTRIBUTORS.
TO THAT WE'VE GOT THAT FOR
HARMLESS DINA THEIR FAMILIES SO
OVER A FEW OF THE SUCCESSFUL
EFFORT IN CALIFORNIA WHICH I
WOULD RATHER GET INTO SOME
OTHER STATES AND HOW ABOUT SOME
OF THE POLICIES THAT MADE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD IF
THERE ARE. NO THAT ONE IS YEARS
AWAY JACQUI THAT HE
DETERMINATION RETALIATED FOR A
SITE WORKERS OFTEN ARE AWARE OF
THEIR P. GENERATED CAME
DISPARITIES AND WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S OFTEN REFERRED TOAS P.
SECRECY POLICIES WHERE
EMPLOYERS DISCOURAGE OVERHEAD
AND POLICE TO TALK ABOUT A
HOUSING PROBLEM AND NOT AND
HE'S WORKERS REALLY REALIZING
THAT THEY HAD CERVANTES IN FACT
NATIONALLY ABOUT 60% OF WORKERS
THE PRIVATE SECTOR EITHER
FORBIDDEN.
OR STRONGLY
DISCOURAGE. THE VERY
SUBSTANTIAL HE'S VERY THAT SHE
EXPERIENCED WITH HER MALE HOW
ORDER ROUTING EXACTING JOB
EIGHTEEN OTHER STATES CANADA
COLOMBIA AFTER THE REVISIONS OF
THE STOCK IN A TYPE OF PEABODY
POLICY MY EMPLOYERS AND WE
ENCOURAGE. FROM OTHER CITIES
ANOTHER AREA THAT OF THIS YEAR
I THOUGHT EIGHT INDIVIDUAL
PRIOR SALARY IN ANY CASE THAT
THE EMPLOYER IS HEADED ARGUED
THAT IT WAS LAWFUL TO PAY HER
LESS THAN HER MALE COLLEAGUES
FOR THE EXACT SAME JOB SIMPLY
BECAUSE YOU EARNED LESS IN A
PRIOR JOB. THE NINTH CIRCUIT
CLEARLY REJECTED THAT ARGUMENT
AND HELD THAT PRIOR SALARY
CANNOT BE DEFENSE UNDER THE
FEDERAL EQUAL PAY ACT
UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS
OBVIOUSLY ON THIS ISSUE HOWEVER
CALIFORNIA OUR EQUAL PAY ADDED
EXPLICITLY SAYS THAT PRIOR
SALARY COULD NOT BE USED TO
JUSTIFY ANY FOUR HUNDRED AND OR
OR EASY WAYS TO THIS AREA OF
THE LAW ON ANY ALSO KNOW THAT
IT HIRING IS ALREADY IN THE
FUTURE AND WEARS OFF ASK. ME
WHICH THEN CAUSES THE
PERPETUATION OF THESE
GENERATION WASTE AFTER OF
COURSE MOST PARTICULARLY HARD
LIKE HE S. SO CALIFORNIA WE
ALSO WANT TO GET IN A PLAYER
FROM ASKING ABOUT PRIOR SALARY
ENSURING THAT THEY ONLY USE
THEY'RE- THAT LAFONTAINE
BONAFIDE FACTORS TO DETERMINE
WHAT WITH VERSION SHOULD BE
PAID. THE IMPORTANT REASON IS
THAT ALREADY BEEN DONE ON OUR
PRAYERS OUR DEAL IN CALIFORNIA
HOLES IN SOME OTHER STATES HAVE
ACTUALLY SHOWN THAT HE PRIOR
SALARY BANDS HAVE HAD THEIR
INTENDED EFFECT AND HAVE
RESULTED IN THEIR OWN THE
OVERALL.
MASON BECAUSE OF THE
FOLDERS AND- ANIMATOR AND THE
CITY SO THEY DECIDED TO PROVIDE
A PROTECTION IS CRITICAL TO
ADDRESS THE INTERNATIONAL
DISCRIMINATION NOT LOOKING. AT
OTHER WOMEN OF COLOR FACE. THE
TALKED ON IS HE UP LET SUMMER.
LAST YEAR LEGISLATURE HAS AT
THE I. SEVENTY THREE WOULD
REQUIRE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS
WITH ONE HUNDRED OR MORE
EMPLOYEES DOES IT APPEAR OR IN
A LEAD TO THE DEPARTMENT
APPARENTLY A HOUSING WHICH
OUTLINED THAT HE THAT HE GAVE
TO THEIR EMPLOYEES. BROKEN DOWN
BY GENDER RACE ETHNICITY JOHN
HENRY. THIS LAW IS A DIRECT
RESPONSE TO THE WAR BACKS ON HE
HAD A COLLECTION OF THE FEDERAL
LEVEL WHEN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HALTED AN OBAMA
ERA- PETER PETER CORNISH'S. AND
IT IS AN IMPORTANT FIRST STEP
TOWARDS ENSURING THAT WE HAVE
MORE FRIENDS HERE AND GET OUT
OF PIZZA SO THAT WE CAN ADDRESS
IT. IMPORTANTLY IT RESIDENTS WE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT TODAY-
OCCUPATIONAL SEGREGATION NO
THAT HE CONSIDERED TO BE ALWAYS
GAP SO WE KNOW THAT NOT ONLY
ARE MALE DOMINATED OCCUPATIONS.
OFTEN AT A HIGHER PACE THEN
EMAIL IT AND WE DON'T LIKE HE
HAS THAT ON HERE MANY OF THE
LOWER PAID OCCUPATIONS BUT EVEN
WITH EIGHT INDIVIDUAL COMPANIES
WE OFTEN SEE PATTERNS HOCKEY.
SEASON WHEREBY WOMEN PEOPLE OF
COLOR IN PARTICULAR TINA'S ARE
OFTEN A FOCUS GAINING
CONCENTRATED IN THE LOWER
CAGES. SO THIS BILL WILL
INITIALLY WERE SHOOTINGS THAT
IS THE LAW ONE THAT EMPLOYERS
UPON CONDUCTING PAY ARTISTS
REQUIRED IMMEDIATE WHO ARE
AGENCIES WILL. POTENTIALLY
HOWEVER DISPARITIES AND
OCCUPATIONAL SEGREGATION THE
WORK WHERE. IT'LL PROMPT THEM
TO ANALYSIS AND RECTIFIED HE
ABSOLUTELY AWFUL BUT ALSO
REALLY IMPORTANTLY ASK THEM TO
SAY HEY WE SEE THAT ALL WHITE
MEN HIS MEDIATION ALMOST ALL
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND I SEEN AS
AN ORDERLY WE NEED TO MAKE
CHANGES TO OUR RECRUITMENT. ARE
HIRING OR RETENTION AND OUR
PROMOTION PRACTICES TO ENSURE
THAT OUR LIMITATION OF LATINOS
AND OTHER WORKERS OF COLOR AND
WOMEN.
AT ALL AGE LEVELS
THROUGHOUT THE COMPANY.
DISCLOSURE NOT INDIVIDUALLY
IDENTIFIABLE NECESSARILY BUT
DISCLOSURE BY COMPANIES- GAS
AND WE'VE ACTUALLY SEEN THAT
WHEN THEY DO HAVE TO DISCLOSE
THEY MORE OFTEN ALSO DISCLOSED
THAT EIGHTY EIGHT STEPS
INCIDENT ACTION PLANS TO
ADDRESS THAT IT IS VERY. SO WE
KNOW THE PUBLIC FOLDERS. IN
FACTORED IN DOLLARS INTRODUCED
AB FOLLOW NINE ONE SEVENTEEN
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE LARGE
COMPANIES TO REPORT BROADBEACH
ENERGIES HE ASKED AND IT HAD
THAT HE HAD A PUBLISHED ONLINE.
DESPITE HAVING THE LEGISLATURE
WITH VETOED AND INFORMATIVE
STEP WOULD BE TO ENSURE SOME
TYPE OF PUBLIC DISCLOSURE OF
MEDIA. THE LAST. ONE WE HAD ON
HERE. WE KNOW WOMEN ARE MORE ON
THAN THE PEOPLE IN FAMILY WHO
WERE CARE TO CHILL OR OTHER
MEMBERS YOU NEED- WE ALSO KNOW
THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE- DETERMINE
AND SOME FROM LAWYER. WHO MADE
IT TO THE OTHER TO DO THEIR JOB
HELLO COMMITTEE ON NOT YOU THEY
ARE SO CRITICAL THAT WE NEED
pTHE FAMILY WAS ON. FOR MANY OF
THE ONE SET SHOWED THAT THAN
HALF OF THE LAST IN NEARLY HALF
OF THE BLACK WOMEN REPORT IF
YOU'RE GETTING. TO CALL OUT OF
THE HEY MOREOVER WE DIDN'T
UNDER JOB INSIGNIFICANT LIKE TO
SAY THAT THEY WERE LIKELY TO HE
WORK BECAUSE. PLEASE ASK YOUR
HIGHER HEATING PROFESSIONALS SO.
IS THERE ANYTHING AGAINST YOUR
YOUR IT IF YOU EVER. AND HE TO
THREE COMMENTING GOT TUESDAY.
THE HARSHEST WILL ON A AS- A
LEAST ONE. NINETY BY C. ANIMALS
SIX ARGUE ACTED TYPE OF CARE TO
I'M JUST. PROTECTION AS WE HOLD
HEALTH WILL MOVE BALL IN ARE
WELL THERE IS A PENDING BILL AS
HE ONE ONE. EIGHTY ONE ONE ONE.
WE CAN DO THAT I. FINALLY I
JUST AND I KNOW. THIS IS TO
COME BEFORE THEM HARD. TO WE
HAVE TO STAY NOW BECAUSE W
HAVE TO OUR SPEAKERS AND WE'RE-
FAR OVER. HELLO CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS VANESSA
HERNANDEZ BAGNOLI. AND I'M
PROUD TO BE HERE TODAY TO
REPRESENT AN ORGANIZATION THAT
REALLY HAS CENTERED THE VOICES
AND EXPERIENCES OF LATINAS FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS. HOPE
HISPANOS ORGANIZE FOR POLITICAL
EQUALITY IS PROUD TO
CONCENTRATE RESOURCES AND
EXPERTISE. TO ENSURING THAT
LATINO SPECIFIC DATA EXISTS.
I'M NOT ONLY EXISTS BUT IS
UTILIZED AT POLICY MAKING
TABLES AND INFORMS POLICIES
THAT IMPACT OUR DAY TO DAY
LIVES AND OUR COMMUNITIES. OUR
ECONOMIC STATUS OF LATINAS
REPORT HAS BEEN AN IMPORTANT
PART OF THIS WORK MANY OF THE
DATA THAT IS HAS BEEN CITED
TODAY IS IN LINE WITH WHAT HAS
BEEN REPORTED IN OUR ESL OUR
REPORT FOR THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
AS WE HEARD EARLIER IN
CALIFORNIA LATINAS MAKE FORTY
TWO CENTS TO THE DOLLAR OF A
WHITE MALE COUNTERPART. AND IN
ADDITION TO THIS DATA. BY
TWENTY TWENTY OUR REPORT
HIGHLIGHTS SOME OTHER NUANCES
THAT I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT
BEFORE MOVING TO SOLUTIONS. WHY
AND I'D LIKE TO UNDERSCORE
AGAIN THAT CALIFORNIA'S PAY GAP
FOR LATINAS IS THE LARGEST IN
THE NATION. SECONDLY I'D LIKE
TO UNDERSCORE. THAT ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THE PAY GAP VARIES
IN PLACES LIKE SAN JOSE IT IS
THE LARGEST AT POINT THIRTY
THREE CENTS PER DOLLAR AND IN
PLACES SUCH AS FRESNO IT'S
CLOSER TO FIFTY CENTS PER
DOLLAR THIS IS IMPORTANT TO
KNOW AS WE LOOK AT SOLUTIONS.
FINALLY I'D LIKE TO UNDERSCORE
AGAIN THE HOPES REPORT FINDS
THAT THE PAY GAP PERSISTS NO
MATTER THE LEVEL OF EDUCATION.
THIS IS A FACT THAT WE CANNOT
IGNORE OR LOOK AWAY FROM. ALL
OF THESE NUANCES ARE IMPORTANT
AS WE CONTINUE TO ELEVATE THIS
CONVERSATION AND FURTHERMORE AS
WE IDENTIFY A VARIETY OF
SOLUTIONS TO MAKE PROGRESS ON
THIS FRONT. THE ROOT CAUSE OF
THE WAGE GAP IS DISCRIMINATION
AS WE'VE HEARD FROM PERSONAL
NARRATIVE IN THE DATA TODAY
ROOTING OUT DISCRIMINATION IS A
CRITICAL PIECE OF THIS
CONVERSATION. NEXT I'D LIKE TO
OFFER A FEW SOLUTIONS TO START
TACKLING THIS ISSUE IN ADDITION
TO ALL THE PROGRESS THAT HAS
BEEN MADE. EARLIER THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON THE
STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS HAS
MENTIONED THE PLEDGE THAT
COMPANIES AND ORGANIZATIONS CAN
TAKE ONLINE THIS INCENTIVE IS
IMPORTANT THE NEXT STEP WOULD
BE TO MAKE IT MANDATORY AND
TRANSPARENT. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
POINT TO A PROMISING PRACTICE
IN MASSACHUSETTS A REALLY
DIVERSE COALITION CALLED THE
WAGE EQUITY NOW IS TACKLING
THIS ISSUE HEAD ON. THEY'RE
CURRENTLY RUNNING LEGISLATION
TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
TRANSPARENCY IN WAGES STATEWIDE
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT IN
CALIFORNIA AS MENTIONED BY
JESSICA THIS DATA ALREADY EXIST
IT IS ALREADY COLLECTED IT IS
JUST NOT AVAILABLE FOR THE
PUBLIC. EQUAL PAY IS CRITICAL
FOR LATINOS AND THE STATE AND
THE FULL ECONOMY HOPE ENVISIONS
A FUTURE WHERE LATINOS ARE PAID
EQUAL PAY FOR EQUAL WORK WHEN
LATINOS ARE SEEN AS LEADERS
CONTRIBUTORS AND CATALYSTS THAT
THEY TRULY ARE. WE ARE
ENCOURAGED BY SPACES LIKE THIS
TO UP LIFT THIS CONVERSATION
AND THE SOLUTION AND WE ARE
ALSO ENCOURAGED TO ADDRESS SO
MANY STRONG LATINOS WHOSE
REPRESENTATION TODAY. IS ALSO A
KEY STRATEGY FOR THIS
CONVERSATION. FINALLY I WANT TO
THANK CHAIRWOMAN GONZALEZ
SUPERVISOR VARGAS AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR ALL OF THEIR
ADVOCACY AND COMMITMENT TO THIS
ISSUE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
BRING HIM BACK MY- SHAME ON YOU
BILL I THINK THAT GOT VETOED BY
GOVERNOR BROWN- ALL RIGHT LAST
BUT CERTAINLY NOT LEAST. WE
HAVE SEEN IT IS FROM THE UCLA
LATINO POLICY AND POLITICS
INITIATIVE- AND I JUST HAVE TO
GIVE A SPECIAL SHOUT OUT- WHEN
WE START UNSEEN LEVINE AS AT
WITH IT YOU KNOW SOMETIMES YOU
ASK PEOPLE FOR HELP YOU ASK FOR
A LITTLE HELP BUT- WE HAVE
RELIED SO HEAVILY ON THE
RESEARCH DONE. AND THE
PRESENTATION STAND BY SONIA AND
HER COLLEAGUES- THAT WERE
HOPING IN THIS NEXT YEAR WE
FIND A PERMANENT HOME FOR THE
UNSEEN LEVINE AS INITIATIVE AT
UCLA THROUGH OUR BUDGET.
PRIORITIES JUST GIVE A LITTLE
SHOUT OUT TO THAT EARLY- BE IN.
A WE HAVE SOME MONEY NEXT YEAR-
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS. IT KEEPS GOING THAT THIS
GOES BEYOND THESE MEMBERS AND
SO IT YOU KNOW I HAVE NEVER
SEEN AN ORGANIZATION RESEARCH
ORGANIZATION STEP UP AND
PROVIDE US WITH SO MANY
RESOURCES AND BE SUCH A
CRITICAL ASPECT ABOUT THE THANK
YOU SONYA AND PLEASE. TAKE US
HOME THAT'S A REALLY SWEET AND
EXCITING BECAUSE I KNOW THAT MY
FACULTY COLLEAGUES HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN EVERY HEARING-
THIS LEGISLATIVE SESSION AND I
THINK THAT'S TREMENDOUS.
BECAUSE WE NEED MORE I THINK
ONE OF THE THINGS WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT LATINAS. THERE EITHER A
MONOLITH- OR THEY ARE INVISIBLE
AND SO THIS UNSEEN MARTINEZ
INITIATIVE HAS GIVEN LIGHT TO
THE DIFFERENT CONTOURS FROM THE
LAW TO MEDIA AND ENTERTAINMENT.
TO WORKERS AND THE STRONG ROLE
THAT LETTING US PLAY AND LATINO
HOUSEHOLDS IN SHAPING AMERICA-
I'M GONNA PROVIDE SOME QUICK
DATA POINTS FOR YOU AND I'M
ALSO GONNA SPEAK TO. WHAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- I THINK BOTH
OF REGINALD JONES SAWYER AND
THEN ALSO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ELOISE GOMEZ REYES ASKED WHICH
IS WHAT WE CAN DO AND I THINK
THAT'S WHERE. WE SHOULD BE
HEADED. SO THESE ARE MY
CONTRIBUTORS THAT PERSON IN THE
MIDDLE BECAUSE UNDER HERNANDEZ
IS THE ONE WHO AUTHORED. THE
EXITING THE WORKFORCE REPORT ON
MEDINA SHE IS NOW AN INCOMING
PHD STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY AND
THE ECONOMICS DEPARTMENT- WE'RE
GOING TO QUICKLY TALK ABOUT THE
STATE OF LATINAS IN THE U. S.
WORKFORCE. WE'RE GONNA DISCUSS
WHY THEY DROPPED OUT OF THE
WORKFORCE SOMEWHERE THIS IS
REALLY SOUNDING THE ALARM BELLS
FOR ALL POLICYMAKERS. WIDER
ECONOMIC CONTRIBUTIONS MATTER
AND THEN ULTIMATELY TO THE LAST
POINT WHAT IS IT THAT WE CAN DO
IS STAKEHOLDERS AND AS
LEGISLATORS- YOU KNOW SOME OF
THE DATA COBA NINETEEN
ESSENTIALLY DECIMATED BLACK AND
BROWN. COMMUNITIES THAT WAS NOT
THE GREAT EQUALIZER. AND WHAT'S
IMPORTANT HERE IS THAT IT WAS
VERY HARMFUL FOR LATINAS WHAT
THIS SHOWS IS THAT AFTER THE
PANDEMIC IN DO SHUTDOWNS RIGHT
THE CLOSURES TO BUSINESS.
LEISURE HOSPITALITY LATINAS
EXPERIENCE HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE THIS WAS TWENTY POINT TWO
PERCENT. MORE THAN ANY OTHER
RACIAL ETHNIC GROUP GENDER X.
CETERA. AND WHAT'S TERRIBLE IS
THAT AS WE CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD FROM COVER NINETEEN
INTO THE VARIANCE INTO. A POST
PANDEMIC REALITY THAT STILL WE
HAVE NOT MET YET CALIFORNIA'S
MUCH FURTHER ALONG THAN THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY. LATINAS
REMAIN AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
UNEMPLOYMENT. NOW DURING THE
PEAK PANDEMIC LATINAS LEFT THE
LABOR FORCE WHEN I DESCRIBE
THIS I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT LEAVING THE LABOR FORCE IS
LIKE DROPPING OUT OF COLLEGE.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE THAT MUCH
MORE TO GET SOMEBODY EN AND THE
REASON THAT THIS MATTERS FOR
LATINAS IS THAT THEIR YOUTHFUL
THEY'RE LEAVING THE LABOR FORCE
NOT. BECAUSE THEY'RE CLOSE TO
RETIREMENT DURING THEIR PEAK
WORK FORCE THIS IS THE PRIME OF
THEIR CAREERS. AND SO LATINAS
EXITED THE WORKFORCE AT A RATE
THAT WAS NEARLY DOUBLE. THAN
WHITE WOMEN. AGAIN LATINAS ARE
THE CURRENT AND FUTURE WORK
FORCE THEY ALSO. ARE THE
BREADWINNERS OF LATINO
HOUSEHOLDS DESPITE THE EQUAL
PAY GAP SO THIS IS NOT JUST
SOMETHING THAT IS AFFECTING.
LATINO HOUSEHOLDS IT'S ALL
AMERICAN HOUSEHOLDS BECAUSE WE
SAW FROM THE TWENTY TWENTY DEBT
DATA. FROM THE CENSUS THERE IS
ONLY ONE DEMOGRAPHIC GROUP THAT
IS NOT GROWING AND THAT'S-
WHITE AMERICANS SO OUR ECONOMY
IS PREDICATED ON WORKERS OF
COLOR. AMERICA'S NEW MAJORITY.
NOW OVER THE COURSE OF THE
PANDEMIC LATINAS A YOU KNOW
DATE ESSENTIALLY EXPERIENCE THE
LARGEST DROP IN LABOR FORCE AND
SAID THIS IS THEM ACCIDENT.
WHERE A YEAR OUT AND IT HAS NOT
RECOVERED AND SO WE HEAR ABOUT
HOW THERE ARE A LOT OF
BUSINESSES THAT CAN'T FILL
THEIR JOBS. WELL ONE OF THE
THINGS IS THINKING ABOUT WHY
THOSE JOBS- ARE NOT WORTH IT SO
MANY LATINOS ESPECIALLY IN
CALIFORNIA LAUGHTER HOUSE EVERY
DAY TO PUT THEIR LIVES AND THE
LIVES OF THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS.
ON THE LINE SO THAT THEY COULD
HAVE A ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD AND
FOOD ON THEIR TABLE THESE WERE
NOT JOBS THAT PROVIDED THE
RETIREMENT SECURITY BENEFITS
THE SICK PAID LEAVE. THE HEALTH
CARE THAT'S QUALITY SO
ULTIMATELY GETTING THOSE
WORKERS BACK IS GOING TO BE
INCUMBENT ON US HAVING GOOD
JOBS INCLUDING GOOD UNION JOBS-
I KIND OF TOUCHED ON THIS BUT-
LATINOS WERE OVERREPRESENTED.
IN VULNERABLE LOW WAGE WORK.
AND SO THIS IS A THIS IS A BAR
CHART THAT SHOWING YOU KNOW THE
WOMEN SHARE POPULATION VERSUS
THEIR SHARE OF LEISURE AND
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY BASED ON.
RACIAL ETHNIC STATUS SO YOU'RE
SAYING THAT LATINOS ARE
OVERREPRESENTED COMPARED TO
THEIR SHARE OF THE US
POPULATION. THIS IS ALSO TRUE
FOR BLACK WOMEN. AND SO THESE
ARE VULNERABLE INDUSTRIES WE
SAW THROUGHOUT TODAY'S HEARING
THE ROLE OF BEING ON THE FRONT
LINES. THE SEXUAL ASSAULTS THE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN THE GROSS-
AN EQUAL ECONOMIC. DEPRIVATION
THAT OCCURS FOR THESE WOMEN
WORKERS. NOW HERE'S ANOTHER
THING THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
IN THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IF
THE INFRASTRUCTURE BILL IS
PASSED THROUGH THE US CONGRESS
WILL. REALLY BE A GAME CHANGER
LATINA SPENT MORE TIME ON
FAMILY CAREVERSUS THEIR MALE
PEERS SAID THE LACK OF HAVING.
AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE OR
ELDERCARE PAID SICK LEAVE YOU
NAME IT MEANT THAT IT WAS
ALMOST- BETTER IN TERMS OF A
SOCIAL UTILITY TO STAY HOME AND
GO TO WORK. AND IT WAS JUST ON
ACCEPTABLE TO HAVE TO PUT YOUR
LIFE ON THE LINE WHEN YOU DID
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO A PROVIDER.
I KNOW THINKING ABOUT YOU-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GÓMEZ REYES
AND IN THE ROLE OF THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND THE LACK OF
PROVIDERS THERE IN HOSPITALS.
ARE YOU GOING TO GO TO WORK FOR
A JOB THAT IS NOT PAIN YOU'RE
NOT GIVING YOU SICK LEAVE AND
PUT YOUR KIDS AT WRESTLE
SCHOOLS ARE CLOSED WE SHOULD
NOT BE MAKING WORKERS IN THEIR
MOST PRODUCTIVE YEARS MAKE
THOSE CHOICES. ESPECIALLY WOMEN
WORKERS- I'M NOT SURE SOMETHING
IN TERMS OF THINKING ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY IN THIS IS NOT JUST
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR LATINOS THIS
IS NOT AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA. TEXAS AND FLORIDA
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO GROW
THE AMERICAN ECONOMY. THERE IS
NO U. S. ECONOMY WITHOUT
LETTING US SO THE LATINO DONOR
COLLABORATIVE FOR THE LAST FOUR
YEARS HAS CREATED A REMARKABLE
REPORT CALLED THE LATINO GROSS
DOMESTIC PRODUCT. THEY WERE
ABLE. TO CALCULATE THAT THIS
YEAR JUST CAME OUT IN
SEPTEMBER- IF LATINOS IN THE U.
S. WHERE THEIR OWN COUNTRY THEY
WOULD BE THE SEVENTH LARGEST
GDP IN THE WORLD. THE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ADDING TWO
POINT SEVEN TRILLION DOLLARS SO
WHEN WE THINKABOUT THE
AMERICAN RECOVERY ACT WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT THE INFRASTRUCTURE
SPENDING THAT IS LATINOS YEAR
AFTER YEAR- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S IMPORTANT IS THAT THEY
ARE THE GROWTH ECONOMY THEY'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO GROW.
AGAIN WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE
DEMOGRAPHIC THAT IS NOT GROWING
THAT IS UNSUSTAINABLE. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT DRIVES THE
SECOND ON THE GROWTH IS LABOR
FORCE PARTICIPATION SO THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS IMPORTANT BUT
ALSO ON THE LINE. GIVEN NOTHING
AS ARE EXITING THE WORKFORCE.
SO BY TWENTY TWENTY NINE OUR
RESEARCH AT UCLA- ANTICIPATES
THAT LATINAS WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALMOST 10% OF
THE US WORK FORCE. NOT WHAT'S
IMPORTANT HERE IS THAT THE
NUMBER OF LATINOS IN THE LABOR
FORCE IS PROJECTED TO GROW. AT
NINE TIMES THE RATE OF THEIR
WHITE FEMALE PEERS. AND SO THEY
NEED TO BE EMPLOYED IN GOOD
JOBS RIGHT GOOD JOBS TO HAVE
DISPOSABLE INCOME. TO GROW THE
ECONOMY TO CONTINUE TO CONSUME
PURCHASE GOODS AND SERVICES.
NOW WHAT CAN GOVERNMENT DO TO
HELP A LOT THERE AND THERE'S A
LOT OF OPPORTUNITY GIVEN THE
ROBUST ARM RESOURCES SO PUBLIC
SECTOR INVESTMENTS THAT MEET
THE MOMENT INCLUDE INCREASING
THE FEDERAL MINIMUM WAGE THIS
JUST HAS TO HAPPEN- ONE OF THE
THINGS WHEN I THINK ABOUT THE
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE WAY IN WHICH WERE ABLE TO
VOTE FOR OUR ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES. IN SOME WAYS
IT'S PARADOXICAL TO PLACES LIKE
FLORIDA WHO VOTE DIFFERENTLY
TOP OF THE TICKET BUT HAVE
PASSED THROUGH BALLOT
INITIATIVES A FIFTEEN DOLLAR
MINIMUM WAGE- IN FRANCHISE MEN
IN VOTING RIGHTS FOR THOSE THAT
WERE FORMALLY INCARCERATED AND
SO SOMETIMES WE CAN LEARN
SOMETHING BY LOOKING EAST BUT
ULTIMATELY WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. AND THE OBLIGATION
TO SHAPE WHAT HAPPENS WEST
EASTWARD AND SO WITHOUT SOME OF
THE OTHER THINGS ARE REALLY
THINKING ABOUT EARLY CHILDHOOD
CARE WHICH I KNOW THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA VESTED A LOT THIS
LAST LEGISLATIVE CYCLE- MAKING
SURE THAT PEOPLE AND HOUSEHOLDS
ARE AWARE OF THIS CHILD TAX
CREDIT SO. EVEN THOUGH WE
CREATE THINGS ARE STILL NEEDS
TO BE THE TRUSTED MESSENGERS
WHETHER IT'S THE UNIONS OR THE
HOPES ARE THE MANASA NDA GOES
OF THE WORLD THAT CAN ACTUALLY
GET THAT MESSAGE OUT AND ENSURE
PEOPLE APPLY- AND THEN
ULTIMATELY WE NEED TO REINFORCE
STATE AND LOCAL I. LAWS THAT
SPECIFICALLY PROHIBIT
DISCRIMINATION. ENFORCEMENT'S A
BIG ISSUE SO WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE COLLATERAL CONSEQUENCES
AND DISCRIMINATORY ENFORCEMENT
AROUND ARE UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS
WERE ON THE FRONT LINES DOING
ESSENTIAL WORK BUT WE'RE NOT
INVESTING THE SAME AMOUNT AS
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AN OSHA AND
MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE SAFE.
PLACES THAT PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY
NOT BEING VICTIMS OF WAGE THEFT
SO THERE NEEDS TO BE AN
IMBALANCE THAT IS CORRECTED
THERE SO THAT IT BALANCES OUT
AND GROWS OUR ECONOMY- I JUST
WANT TO CLOSE AND SAY THANK YOU
I THINK THAT WE ALL HAVE A ROLE
TO PLAY IN THIS AND IF WE DON'T
DO SOMETHING NOW. WE ALL WILL
BE SCREWED. THANKS THANK YOU.
THE LAST NIGHT I. AND I WANT TO
THE STATE BECAUSE I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN TO BE QUITE I'M
JUST START BY THAT YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES I GET FRUSTRATED
BECAUSE IF YOU LOOK AT THE
THINGS WE'VE DONE AND SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT ARE SUGGESTED
WE'VE DONE IT YOU KNOW WE SAID
YOU CAN'T ASK ABOUT PRIOR-
SALARY SALARY WE SAID THERE'S
GOTTO BE SOME TRANSPARENCY- WE
WORKED ON THE BILL WIH THEM SO
MUCH OF IT WE WORK WITH THAT
ARE FORMERSENATOR HANNAH BETH
JACKSON WHO. REALLY LED THE WAY
ON A LOT OF THE STUFF YOU KNOW
WE'VE EXPANDED PAID LEAVE WE'VE
INCREASED THE MINIMUM WAGE I
MEAN YOU NAME IT WE'VE DONE IT
RIGHT WE CONTINUE TO LEAD AND
YET CALIFORNIA IS FURTHER
BEHIND AND CONTINUE TO FALL
EVEN FARTHER BEHIND THAN THE
REST OF THE NATION AND DURING
THE PANDEMIC- I MEAN WITH THE
NUMBER YOU'LL SEE. YOU KNOW-
LATINOS NATIONWIDE WERE ABOUT
FIFTY FIVE CENTS A DOLLAR NOW
FIFTY SEVEN I THINK THAT'S
PROBABLY BECAUSE SOME OF THE
STATE'S IT LIFTED THE MINIMUM
WAGE PROBABLY HELPED AND
PROBABLY LATINAS WHO DROPPED
OUT OF WORKFORCE CHANGE THE
NUMBERS UNFORTUNATELY ON FROM
THAT BUT EVEN IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE THAT HAPPENS- WE'RE STILL
FORTY TWO CENTS SO WHAT. AT
IT'S FRUSTRATING BECAUSE IN
SOME WAYS IT'S LIKE WHAT ARE WE
DOING WRONG AND I DO THINK THAT
THAT THERE IS DISCRIMINATION
BUT WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR SISTERS
WHO ARE AFRICAN AMERICAN THERE
THEY I WOULD ARGUE FACE THE
SAME IF NOT MORE DISCRIMINATION
AT LEAST EQUAL DISCRIMINATION
LEVINE AS SO LIKE WHAT IS IT
LIKE WHAT CAN WE DO- WHY IS
CALIFORNIA FALLING SO YEAH.
WELL I THINK THAT CALIFORNIA'S
FALLING BEHIND BECAUSE WE'RE
GROWING INCOME INEQUALITY AND
SO IT'S A TALE OF THE RICHES
WHICH IN ENDEAVORED THIS HUGE
SURPLUS BUT WITH THAT WE HAVE
TO BE CREATIVE SO THE UNIVERSAL
STRATEGY IN CALIFORNIA IS NOT
THE STRATEGY THAT WE NEED TO
RELY FULLY ON WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT TARGETS SO WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT YOU KNOW WE'VE DONE ALL
OF THESE THINGS I. I THINK
ABOUT THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC SO SURE WE HAD A LOT
OF VACCINES BUT THERE WAS A LOT
OF WORK TO DO TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE VACCINES ACTUALLY GOT TO
FRONTLINE ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND
SO THERE WHAT WAS REQUIRED AS
COMMUNITY CLINICS AND NOT
INFRASTRUCTURE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND TRUSTED
MESSENGERS- SO I THINK THAT THE-
IN THE SAN. NEEDS TO GO THE
POPULAR. FOR INFORM. VERSUS
LETTING IT FIRST IN TIME THAT'S
NOT GONNA WORK. AND THEN THE
SECOND THING IS THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO DOUBLE DOWN AND
GROWING OUR CIVIL SOCIETY
INFRASTRUCTURE. ULTIMATELY WITH
THE SPREAD OF DISINFORMATION
AND MISINFORMATION WE'RE SEEING
THAT PEOPLE'S TRUST IN
GOVERNMENT IS NOT WHERE IT
NEEDS TO BE IN THOSE NOT ARE
NOT ALWAYS THE BEST MESSENGERS.
BUT IF YOU GO TO WORK SITE
SERVE YOU'RE GOING TO COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS- IF YOU'RE GOING
TO SCHOOLS SCHOOLS ARE REALLY
GOOD SITE FOR REACHING LATINO
FAMILIES IN ASIAN AMERICAN
FAMILIES. BECAUSE THEIR
YOUTHFUL THAT COULD PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY AND SO I THINK IT'S
JUST AMOUNT OF. TARGETING AND
THEN ENSURING YOU HAVE THE
PEOPLE AND THE BOOTS ON THE
GROUND THAT CAN GET THAT
MESSAGE. THAT PEOPLE GO FROM
ACCESS TO ACTUALLY APPLYING.
AND MATRICULATING INTO ANY SORT
OF GOVERNMENT PROGRAM. THANK
YOU ARE THEIR DIVISIONAL I'M
SURE THERE'S ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS. CRISTINA AND THEN. I
THINK THERE'S MORE OF A COMMENT
ON YOUR LAST SET OF YOUR
RESPONSE- WITH THE VACCINE IN
PARTICULAR I WANT TO MAKE IT
CLEAR TO THOSE WITHIN THAT
THERE ARE GROUPS ON THE GROUND
WHO ARE DOING THE WORK AND ARE
THE RESPECTED AND TRUSTED
pMESSENGERS I THINK WE HAVE A
SYSTEM WITHIN OUR GOVERNMENT
THAT TRIES TO FORCE A MODEL
THAT THIS AND WORK WITH AND
WHAT WE HAPPENS I THINK WE NEED
TO. FIRST AND FOREMOST WE THINK
THAT- IS TO SAY THAT THERE'S
NOTHING THERE- WHEN WE NEED
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE WHETHER TO
GIVE ACTINGSOUTH P. P. OR EVEN
INFORMATION ABOUT OUR RIGHTS
THAT ARE OUT THERE ARE IN SEOUL
DEFINITELY INTERESTED IN IDEAS
OF HOW WE START TO CHANGE THAT
NARRATIVE FROM OUR POSITION- SO
THAT WE'RE PUTTING TO WORK THE
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE WE ARE
RESOURCE RICH COMMUNITY OUT
THERE BUT WHEN YOU TALK TO
FOLKS WHO ARE AT THE LIKE
THERE'S NOTHING AVAILABLE I'M
LIKE WELL THERE'S NOTHING
AVAILABLE AND THE WAY THAT IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN NUMBER THAT HASN'T.
WORKED FOR US IN THE WITHIN
THAT WATER SOME RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE FOR US SO I
THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT RATE
AND I THINK ABOUT THE PAST
NINETEEN MONTHS THAT WE'VE ALL
EXPERIENCED IN THIS COLLECTIVE
PSYCHE THAT IS TRANSFORM THE
WAY THAT WE LIVE WORK AND EVEN
PLAY- AND SO WE NEED TO
REMEMBER THAT COBEN NINETEEN IS
NOT THE LAST CRISES WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE WILD FIRES
WE SEE NOT FOR THE LAST FOUR
YEARS WE DON'T KNOW WHAT OTHER
PUBLIC EPIDEMIC IS GOING TO BE
THERE WE KNOW WE HAVE. GROSS
HOUSING AND SECURITY AND SO HOW
CAN WE STABILIZE OUR CIVIL
SOCIETY SECTOR SO THAT THEY CAN
BE RESPONSIVE FOR THIS RESEARCH
HEAVY- JURISDICTION THAT WERE
ANSWER THOSE RESOURCES ACTUALLY
PENETRATE SOME OF THE THINGS I
THINK ABOUT IS THAT YOU KNOW
THERE ARE TIMES WERE DIGITAL
MATTERS AND THERE'S TIMES WERE
DIGITAL FIRST DOESN'T AND SO
WHEN YOU HAVE ACCESS TO
SOMETHING SO VITAL THAT IS LIFE
OR DEATH SURELY. BASED ON
INTERNET AND A SYSTEM THAT IS
NOT CULTURALLY COMPETENT OR
EASY TO USE AND SOMETHING THAT
MAYBE AS EASY FOR TWENTY YEAR
OLDS AND THIRTY YEAR OLDS THEY
WERE MISSING THE MARK- AND
THAT'S WHY YOU'RE STILL GONNA
NEED OBVIOUSLY THAT
MOBILIZATION I DO. A LOT OF
WORK ON VOTING RIGHTS AND-
ELECT. ENGAGE YOU CAN NOT TO
PHONE CALLS AND SMS AS THE-
ONLY WAY TO. PEOPLE YOU NEED TO
DOOR KNOCKING NEEDS TO ENSURE
THAT YOU'RE MEETING PEOPLE
WHERE THEY ARE. ESPECIALLY IF
THE FIRST TIME VOTERS ARE LOW
PROPENSITY VOTERS. USE THAT
ANALOGY FOR ANY SORT OF
GOVERNMENT CRISES RESPONSE IN
THE FUTURE. ERIC YOUNG
ORGANIZERS. NOT ALL BY TEXT.
ELOISE I LOVE HEARING THAT
BECAUSE THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
WE'RE THE OLDER THE OLDER
GENERATION TALKS ABOUT IS THE
DOOR KNOCKING UP SOMETHING YOU
SAID I THINK REALLY RESONATED
HE SAID SOME OF THOSE JOBS JUST
AREN'T WORTH IT OUR OUR-
LATINOS ARE REALIZING THAT
THEY'RE THEY'RE BEING ABUSED-
IT THEY'RE BEING USED IN A WAY
THAT IS THAT IS WRONG AND THEY
NOW ARE HEARING ABOUT ALL THESE
OTHER JOBS AND REALIZE THAT
THEY'RE GIVING UP THEIR FAMILY
TIME THEY'RE GIVING UP SO MUCH
FOR THOSE MENIAL JOBS SO I
APPRECIATE THAT- YOU'VE TALKED
ABOUT GROWING OUR CIVIL SOCIETY
SECTOR. THAT'S IT'S A NEW
PHRASE FOR ME. PLEASE TELL US
MORE ABOUT THAT YEAH SO THIS
CAN BE MAJOR SOCIAL- SERVICES
AGENCIES LIKE IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA WOULD BEAT THE UNITY
COUNCIL- IN THE FRUITVALE
SERVICE AGENCIES THAT RECEIVE
FEDERAL FUNDS OR STATE FUNDS TO
DO WORK ON YOU CAN THINK ABOUT
ON. CHILDCARE SENIOR CITIZENS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- HEAD START
THOSE ARE PLACES THAT DURING
THE PANDEMIC WERE ESSENTIALLY
TRANSITIONING FROM THOSE
SERVICES TO GIVING PEOPLE FOOD
AND CASH ASSISTANCE. NOW IN
ADDITION THERE'S THE CIVIL
SOCIETY COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AT A REGIONAL
LEVEL RIGHT THERE COULD BE
PEOPLE- LIKE C. LRA OUR YOU CAN
THINK ABOUT YOU KNOW- YOU KNOW
I THINK ABOUT NOT A THINK ABOUT
HOPE I ALSO THINK ABOUT PLACES
THAT DO WORK FOR YOUTH
ENGAGEMENT. THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PLACES THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE POSSIBLE BECAUSE OF SOCIAL
POLICY THROUGH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT STATE GOVERNMENT BUT
THEY'RE NOT GOVERNMENT. BUT THE
GREAT THING ISOFTENTIMES THERE
BY PARK LEAD. AND THEY'RE BEING
LED BY PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE DEALING
WITH YOUR THING YOU'RE DEALING
WITH HOUSING AND LOW INCOME
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. SO THOSE
ARE PLACES TO INVEST SO THAT
THEY CAN GET THE MESSAGE OUT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I THINK
IS REALLY IMPORTANT WHEN WE
WHEN WE POSITION THIS WITHIN
OUR CULTURE AND OUR COMMUNITY
IN THE HISTORY OF LATINOS
ALWAYS BEING HERE. ONE OF THE
GREATEST OUTCOMES OF THE LATINO
MOVEMENT WAS THE COMMUNITY
HEALTH CARE AND PUBLIC HEALTH
FIGHTS BECAUSE WE STILL NOW
WENT FROM ACCESS TO SOCIAL
SERVICES POVERTY ALLEVIATION TO
THIS ROBUST NETWORK OF
COMMUNITY CLINICS. WHO ARE NOT
ONLY PROVIDING HEALTH CARE BUT
ARE TELLING PEOPLE WHEN TO VOTE
HOW TO REGISTER TO VOTE RIGHT
WITH THE AFORDABLE CARE ACT
THAT BECAME A HUGE POLITICAL
FIGHT IT'S STILL NOT OVER
THROUGH THE COURTS BUT THAT'S A
PLACE WHERE YOU WANT TO ENGAGE.
THESE PATIENTS AND YOU CAN
DISSEMINATE INFORMATION BECAUSE
THERE'S A THRESHOLD YOU KNOW
THAT THOSE ARE GOING TO BE LOW
INCOME PATIENTS OR THEIR
PATIENTS THAT ARE MEDICALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY UNDERSERVED.
THANK YOU. YUP IF I MAY WITH
THE- FROM HOPE. THANK YOU ALL
THANK YOU. VANESSA YOU TALKED
ABOUT THIS REPORT THAT YOU ALL
HAD PUT TOGETHER- YOU ALSO
TALKED ABOUT AN ORGANIZATION
WAGE EQUITY NOW YOU TALKED
ABOUT THE TRANSPARENCY AND
WAGES IT IS THIS REPORT
AVAILABLE TO US ALSO YEAH
DEFINITELY ON HOPE'S WEBSITE WE
HAVE A SERIES OF LATINA
SPECIFIC REPORTS ALL ON- OUR
WEBSITE WHICH IS LIKE THE NEST
.ORG BACKSLASH REPORTS IN
ADDITION TO THE ECONOMIC STATUS
OF LATINAS REPORT WE ALSO HAVE
A TON OF DATA ABOUT LATINOS
STARTING MICRO BUSINESSES. AND
ENTREPRENEURS THAT OUR
COMMUNITY IS SO I WERE BUILDING
TOWARDS A LARGER LATINO
SPECIFIC DATA HOPE AND WE HOPE
TO SEE IT GROW IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND IF I MAY
OUR COMMISSIONER. LILIA
SOMETHING SHE SAID THERE'S
ACTUALLY THE TRUTH AND IT IS
SIMILAR TO WHAT SCIENCE CENTER
HAD TALKED ABOUT IS THAT WE
DON'T ALL START ON EQUAL
FOOTING AND WE HAVE TO STOP
PRETENDING THAT WE'RE STARTING
AT THE SAME LEVEL WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT EQUALITY EQUALITY IS THE
WRONG WORD IT HAS TO BE EQUITY
WE HAVE TO BRING EVERYBODY UP
TO THE SAME LEVEL BEFORE YOU.
YOU START LIFTING EVERYBODY UP-
RIGHT. HOLLY FROM THE K. COUNTY
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN ALL RIGHT I WAS ON THE
BOARD- AND RECENTLY BUT- THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON THE
STATUS OF WOME HAS GOT TO BE.
A STRONGER VOICE IT HAS TO BE
THAT ORGANIZATION THAT THE
MEDIA GOES TO ASK FOR AN
OPINION. AS AS THEY DO IT
SHOULDTO DO FOR HOPE AND MANY
OF OUR OTHER- ORGANIZATIONS.
BUT THE PRESENCE OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON STATUS
OF WOMEN. I BELIEVE CAN BE A
LOT. CAN BE SO MUCH STRONGER- I
THINK ALL OF THESE THE
PRESENTERS TODAY. TWENTY OKAY
THANK YOU TO THIS THE LAST
PANEL INCREDIBLY INFORMATIVE.
ONE OF THE COMMENTS AT SEVERAL
COMMENTS ACTUALLY BUT IN
PARTICULAR AT MISSONI IDEAS
WITH THESE SILLY LOOKING A
POLICY POLITICS INITIATIVE-
WITH REGARDS. TO- WITH HOW
LATINOS ARE WOMEN SPECIFICALLY
ARE NOT EQUAL FOOTING BUT IN
MANY WAYS HE SAID SOMETHING
THAT MANY FOLKS HAVE TOLD ME-
WITH RELATIONS TO MY JOB IN THE
ASSEMBLY OUR PRIME EARNING
YEARS. WHEN THE LEGISLATURE WAS
MOSTLY WHITE WHEN IT WAS MOSTLY
MALE UP UNTIL PROP ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN TIMES IN NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR LEGISLATORS HAD. A PENSION
THEY HAD HEALTH BENEFITS THEY
HAD ALL THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE
TO THEM. THE MOMENT THAT
LATINOS BEGAN- GAINING
POLITICAL POWER AND MOSTLY AT
THE BEGINNING OR THE BEGINNING
IT WAS MOSTLY LATINO MEN. AND
THEY'RE WITH THE CHEFS THANKS
TO MANY OF THE WOMEN HERE IS-
INCLUDING OUR OUR CHAIR FOR THE
SELECT COMMITTEE THERE WAS AN
INTENTIONAL SHIFT TO FIND AND
ELECT MORE LATINA. INTO THE
LEGISLATURE IN THAT TIME. SO
MANY THINGS HAVE HAPPENED
PROPOSITIONS HAVE GONE INTO
EFFECT WHERE LEGISLATORS NO
LONGER HAVE A PENSION. AND NO
LONGER HAVE THE BENEFITS THE
HEALTHCARE BENEFITS THAT USED
TO EXIST AT ONE POINT MEANING
THAT AS OUR GOVERNMENT AS WE
RELATED TO GOVERNMENT IN THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT- WHO HAS
POWER. AS THE LEGISLATURE TURN
TO BE MORE PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
MORE WOMEN OF COLOR. THE
BENEFITS TO THIS POSITION HAVE
ALMOST DISAPPEARED COMPLETELY
THERE IS NO PENSION WE PAY FOR
HEALTHCARE WE DON'T HAVE THE
SAME RESOURCE THEM AND BENEFITS
THAT USED TO EXIST TO WHITE MEN
WHEN THEY WERE IN POWER.
MEANING THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
AN INTENTIONAL SACRIFICE THAT
TAKES PLACE TO BE HERE. I KNOW
THAT GIVEN THE GRAPHICS THAT WE
SAW TODAY IN MY AGE BRACKET I
AM ACTUALLY EARNING LESS THAN
WHAT I WAS BEFORE I CAME TO THE
LEGISLATURE. AND WILL EARN LESS
ALSO BASED ON MY AGE BRACKET
WHEN I GRADUATED COLLEGE I
GRADUATED DURING- BUT LUCKILY I
WAS ABLE TO GRADUATE COLLEGE
AND NOT BE. A STUDENT I WENT IN
AND THEN DROPPED OUT BUT IT WAS
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT AND HARD-
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAL STATE AND
THEN FINALLY A GRADUATE SCHOOL.
AND I KNOW THAT I AM EARNING
LESS THAN THE GENERATIONS THAT
CAME BEFORE ME. AND THAT IS A
REALITY SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT.
THE LATINA PAY EQUITY GAP IN
TERMS OF WORKING CLASS WOMEN
MIDDLE CLASS EARNERS HIGH
INCOME EARNERS THE C. SUITE
WHATEVER LOOKS LIKE THERE IS A
HUGE GAP. AND EVEN WITHIN THE
GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE. WHY WOULD
WE WANT TO DO THIS JOB IS A
HUGE HUGE QUESTION IT TAKES YOU
AWAY FROM YOUR FAMILY IT TAKES
YOU AWAY FROM YOUR COMMUNITY
YOUR OFTEN ISOLATED IN
SACRAMENTO AND LUCKILY FOR SOME
OF US WERE ABLE TO BUILD
COMMUNITY AND BE ABLE TO PUSH
THINGS FORWARD WHICH IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO HAVE
THAT ALLY SHIP IN PARTNERSHIP.
BUT IT IS DIFFICULT AND EVEN
WITHIN GOVERNMENT AGAIN TO THE
QUESTION AND THIS IS A
CONVERSATION THAT I HAD WITH
ANOTHER COLLEAGUE FROM MY VERY
AFFLUENT AREA WITH RELATIONS TO
COLD IN THE GRAPHICS THAT WE
SAW THAT IMPACTED MORE WOMEN
AND WOMEN OF COLOR LETTING US
SPECIFICALLY AND THAT SIXTY
THOUSAND. PLUS PEOPLE THAT HAVE
DIED ACROSS THE STATE BECAUSE
OF COAL BUT IN THE LAST
NINETEEN MONTHS MOST OF WHOM
HAVE BEEN THE LATINO COMMUNITY
AND WOMEN. NOT EVERYONE
EXPERIENCE THE PANDEMIC IN THE
SAME WAY. AND SO I REMEMBER
HAVING A CONVERSATION WITH A
COLLEAGUE FROM AN AFFLUENT AREA
WHO WAS TELLING ME THAT- THEY
HAD ALL OF THEIR CVS'S AND ALL
OF THEIR PHARMACIES HAD THE
COVERT VACCINE AND THEY HAD AN
OVERSUPPLY MEANWHILE MY
COMMUNITY WHICH IS SPLIT BY A
FREEWAY ONE SIDE IS AFFLUENT
ONE SIDE IS 20% BELOW THE
NATIONAL POVERTY LINE. WE
COULDN'T GET THE VACCINE WE
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET MY COMMUNITY DIDN'T
HAVE ACCESS TO THE INTERNET WE
COULDN'T GET AN APPOINTMENT R.
DIGER STADIUM IS IN MY DISTRICT
ND GO DODGERS THE PLUG. BUT
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A CAR. YOU
HAVE TO HAVE TURNED YOU HAD TO
HAVE PERSONAL TRANSPORTATION TO
BE ABLE TO BE IN A LINE FOR
HOURS TO RECEIVE A TEST OR TO
RECEIVE A VACCINE IF YOU ARE A
LOW WAGE WORKER WITHOUT A CAR
WHO LIVES IN PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION THERE WAS NO
ACCESS TO YOU. FOR A MONTH AND
WE WERE HAVING THE
CONVERSATIONS EVEN IN
SACRAMENTO WE NEED PILOT
PROGRAMS WITH COMMUNITY CLINICS
AND- OUR SCHOOLS WHICH ARE
TRUSTED SITES SO THAT OUR
COMMUNITY COULD HAVE ACCESS
MULTI GENERATIONAL FAMILIES
LIVING. IN ONE HOME GRANDMOTHER
MOTHER CHILDREN GRANDKIDS AT TO
BE ABLE TO FULLY HAVE ACCESS TO
THIS THESE RESOURCES AND IT
TOOK MONTHS FOR US TO GET THERE
COLLEAGUES AND CONVINCING- THE
SACRAMENTO STRUCTURE TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE EVEN PILOT PROGRAMS.
TO PIVOT THIS GIANT TECTONIC
THAT WE KNEW WAS IMPACTING OUR
COMMUNITIES THE MOST THIS IS
WHY THIS CONVERSATION IS
IMPORTANT THIS IS WHY THE
EXPERTS IN THE FIELD ARE
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THESE
CONVERSATIONS WERE NOT
HAPPENING IN A PUBLIC WAY AND
HAVE BEEN LACKING FOR QUITE
SOME TIME AND I THINK THAT WE
ARE MOVING FORWARD AND AN
INCREDIBLE POWERFUL DIRECTION.
TO BE ABLE TO REALLY SIGNIFY
THAT IN ORDER FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES TO THRIVE AND IF WE
ARE TRULY GOING TO LOOK AT
LEVINE AS BEING THE LARGEST
POPULATION IN THE STATE AND
THE- THE BREADWINNERS AND MANY
FAMILIES AND THE LATINO
COMMUNITY GROWING BEING THE
FASTEST GROWING. POPULATION
ACROSS THE NATION THEN IT IS A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE FUTURE
OF OUR STATE AND THE FUTURE OF
THIS COUNTRY THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
TIED WITH ECONOMIC JUSTICE
INCOME INEQUALITY WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT- AND CLEARLY
REPRESENTATION THAT MATTERS AND
THAT BRINGS THOSE VOICES TO THE
TABLE SO I'M JUST I THINK
THERE'S SO MUCH WORK AND SO
MANY IDEAS THAT ARE GOING TO
COME OUT OF THIS HEARING TODAY
AND HOW WE ARE ABLE TO MOVE.
SESSION IN JUST A FEW MONTHS
THANK YOU THANK YOU. READY M.
I'M A FIRM. GIVE ME I'M A FIRM
BELIEVER IN. WELL SOME IS THE
START BREEDING. GET YOUR OWN
BREATH BACK IN YOUR MOUTH THIS
ALWAYS GOOD- I'M A FIRM
BELIEVER IN AND NOT REINVENTING
THE WHEEL- WHEN I FIRST STARTED
TO GET INVOLVED IN AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION THERE WAS THIS
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHITE MEN. AND
THE FACT THAT AFTER AMERICAN
MEN COULDN'T KEEP PACE AND IT
WAS CHAU LOS SIX- I'M OLDER
THAN A LOT OF UNITS FROM CHAU.
HI THIS IS WHEN WE HAD
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. THEN IT
BECAME A DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW
WHAT WHITE WOMEN WERE OUTPACING
BLACK MEN AND NEITHER ONE OF US
IS CATCHING UP WITH WHITE MEN-
AND NOW. WHEN I BRING THIS UP
ABOUT YOU KNOW BRING IT BACK
FROM A FACTION FOR WOULD WE
NEED TO DO TO BE INTENTIONAL.
SO THAT WE COULD WE COULD EVEN
THINGS- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WAS INTERESTING I WOULD GET
PUSHED BACK. FROM WHITE MEN WHO
WOULD SAY YEAH BUT LOOK A BLACK
WOMEN. IN A RESEARCH ISSUE THAT
SHOWED A BLACK WOMAN WERE
OUTPACING WHITE MEN GOING TO
COLLEGE THEIR ORDER DO MORE
BLACK WOMEN ON BOARDS IN THE
BLACK MEN. BOB MY SISTERS ARE
DEFINITELY DOING SOME RIGHT.
THEY ARE STARTING TO FIGURE
THIS COMPLEX THING OUT OR ITS
INTENTIONAL LIKE THEY THE
PREDOMINATE GROUP ONLY WANT TO
WHITE WOMEN ON BOARDS ONLY WANT
TO WORK HAVE THEM GET CONTRACT.
NOW MAYBE IT'S SHIFTED TO THAT
BUT I AND THIS IS PROBABLY MORE
FOR THE UCLA POLICY INITIATIVE
TO. LET'S NOT REINVENT THE
WHEEL LET'S SEE WHAT HAS GONE
ON IN THE PAST LET'S EXAMINE
WHY. BLACK WOMEN WHITE WOMEN
FIRST NOW BLACK WOMEN ARE
STARTING TO MOVE UP. AND THEN
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY ELIMINATE
WHATEVER THOSE WHO DOES DOES
PREJUDICIAL BARRIERS TO KEEP
CERTAIN GROUPS DOWN THE THIRD
RISING HAVE LISTED TRYING TO
GET EVERYBODY TO RISE A ONE
TIME THEY PICK AND CHOOSE. WHO
THEY WANT TO RISE AT A CERTAIN
TIME BUT ALWAYS KEEP A CERTAIN
SEGMENT. DOWN OR PUSH THEM DOWN
AND SO. I THINK THERE MAY BE
SOME VALUABLE LESSONS. THAT AND
I'VE ALWAYS SUGGESTED THAT WE
STARTED LOOK AT HOWLAND. AFTER
MEREKA WOMEN HAVE BECOME
EXTREMELY POWERFUL WHETHER
IT'S- STACEY ABRAMS TADESE
HOLLY MITCHELL TO THE WEST WE
HAVE SOME. POWERFUL WOMEN AND
EVEN WITH MY LATINA GROUP THAT
ADVISES ME ON WHAT I NEED TO DO
EVERY DAY. SOME OF SITTING HERE-
THEY WOULD SAY YOU KNOW AFTER
AMERICANS YOU GUYS ARE REALLY
FORCEFUL WAY MAYBE CUT BECAUSE
OUR WOMEN. ARE REALLY STRONG
AND FORCEFUL AND THEY'RE
LEADING THE WAY A LOT OF WAYS.
AND SO WERE YOU KNOW WE MATTER
JUST HOLDING ONTO THE COAT
TAILS IN THIS GOING GETTING
THROUGH THE DOOR MAYBE WE NEED
TO START LOOKING AT. THE
PRACTICES THE PROCEDURES OF
WHAT THEY'RE DOING TO GET TO
THAT NEXT LEVEL AND THEN SHARE
THAT KNOWLEDGE WITH EVERYONE SO
WE CAN BRING OURSELVES UP. AND
NOT. DEPEND ON ANYBODY ELSE.
RUSSIAN YES THANK YOU I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE SECOND PANEL AS
WELL IT WAS VERY INFORMATIVE I
MEAN I'M A POWER POINT GIG SO I
LOVE THE SLIDES I THINK ONE OF
THE POINTS THAT WE HAVE A TALK
SO MUCH ABOUT BECAUSE YES WE
HAVE A BOSS YES WE NEED MORE
ENFORCEMENT YES THERE'S MORE WE
CAN DO BUT THERE'S A WHOLE GAP
THAT I THINK WAS MENTIONED AND
I DON'T WANT TO FALL AWAY IT'S
ABOUT THE RESKILLING AND
UPSKILLING- OF LATINOS TO
ENSURE WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT
THE CHANGE IN THE WORK FORCE.
TO ENSURE THAT THERE ARE ALSO
PROFITING FROM ALL THE CHANGES
IN EDUCATION AND- AND
TECHNOLOGY TECHNOLOGICAL
INNOVATION CHALLENGES ARE GOING
ON THE STATE SO I LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON THAT AND
HEARING MORE ABOUT THAT IN
MAKING SURE THAT THE- LAND AND
SEA LATINOS AND **** GETS HOME.
THE BOARD BANANA THING YOU ALL
YOUR YOU'RE ALWAYS ARE
ADJACENTLY TINA- I SAY THAT
WITH MUCH LOVE AS YOU KNOW I
JUST I BEFORE WE AND THIS
HEARING AND I WANT TO POINT OUT
I YOU KNOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
COMMITTEE CLINICS AND- WE HAVE
ON A MEDICAL SAID HERE FROM ANY
FUTURE HEALTH CLINIC AND REALLY
PARTNER. I MEAN TO BE HONEST WE
SHOULD LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED IN
SAN DIEGO DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND I THINK I MADE SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES JEALOUS BECAUSE WE
HAD A UNIQUE SITUATION WE HAD-
JUST A NEWLY ELECTED LIKING A
SUPERVISOR FOR THE FIRST TIME-
AND- WE- HADN'T. AT THE TIME
THE CHAIR LATINO CAUCUS WHO-
HAPPEN TO SLEEP WITH THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS CHAIR. SO HE GOT
HERE AND EVERY DAY. BUT IT WAS
THAT INTENTIONALITY I YOU KNOW
EARLY ON WE THOUGHT WITH THE
TESTING SO WE STARTED SAYING ON
THE VACCINES LIKE IT CAN'T JUST
BE. ONE SIZE FITS ALL THERE HAS
TO BE A DIRECTIVE- FOR THE
SOUTH BAY. AND I'M IN ACTUALLY
I'D LOVE TO SEE THE DATA I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING WE NEED
EXPLORER. BECAUSE WE WERE
HOUSED IN THE SOUTH BAY WE
REALLY DID A GOOD JOB IN THE
SOUTH BAY OF- AND PRESSURING
THE COUNTY BOARD. TO TAKE CARE
OF OUR FOLKS IN TO BE DELIVERED
THAT WE HAVE THAT SOME OF HIGH
SPEC SEEN RATES IN FACT WE'RE
WE'RE- BASICALLY FOR ELIGIBLE-
ADULTS IN IN THE SOUTH BAY
SOUTH OF THE- NINETY FOUR.
WE'RE ALMOST AS CLOSE AS YOU
CAN GET A 100% VACCINATED
BASICALLY- AND THAT'S BECAUSE
IT WAS INTENTIONAL AND WE
WORKED SO HARD ON THAT. BUT IT
WOULD BE INTERESTING EVEN TO
SEE WHAT HAPPENED IN NORTH
COUNTY WHERE WE DIDN'T HAVE THE
REPRESENTATION NECESSARILY AND
WE TRIED I MEAN I- YOU KNOW YOU
YOU TEND TO FOCUS ON WHERE YOU
LIVE- IN AND- HAVING.
ORIGINALLY COME FROM THE NORTH
CAN WILL WORK WITH TOUCH AND
TRY TO GET SOME THINGS BUT WE
WERE A LITTLE DELAYED- AND SO
IT'S INTERESTING HOW IMPORTANT
REPRESENTATION IS OUR
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR
COMMUNITY CLINICS OUR
RELATIONSHIPS WITH. OUR NGOS-
BUT I'M I'M REALLY PROUD OF
WHAT WE WERE ABLE TO DEAL- BUT
IT'SNOT ENOUGH AND WE CAN'T
STOP SO I APPRECIATE THAT THE
WORDS THAT ALWAYS COME OUT- THE
INTENTIONALITY. UNAPOLOGETIC
I'M REPRESENTATION BY LATINOS.
WE NEED FOR THOSE WHO DON'T
KNOW I THINK. I THINK CRISTINA
GARCIA AND SOME OTHERS ALLUDED
TO IT WE RIGHT WHEN I STARTED
LEGISLATURE WE HAVE FIVE
LATINOS IN BOTH HOUSES. AND WE
DID START TO- AND THEN WE LOST
TWO AND WE START TO WORRY WHAT
IS GONNA HAPPEN I MEAN HERE WE
WERE THE LARGEST DEMOGRAPHIC
CALIFORNIA. AND WE WERE- YOU
KNOW LESS THAN 2% OF
LEGISLATORS. AND WE MADE THE
INTENTIONAL DECISION TO ASK OUR
MALE COLLEAGUES LATINO MALE
COLLEAGUES TO REPLACE
THEMSELVES WITH A LATINA- AND
OVER THE YEARS THE- GOOD LORD
NINE YEARS WE'VE BEENTHERE-
LEVINE IS NOW OUT NUMBER LET
THE NOTE IN THE LEGISLATURE
CLOSE TO TWENTY SO WE'RE- WE'RE
NOT YET. AT OUR REPRESENTATIVE
PROPORTION BUT DEFINITELY HAVE
MADE A HUGE DENT. WITHOUT
BECAME BECAUSE EVERY SINGLE DAY
WE BEAT THE DRUM EVERY SINGLE
DAY WE SAID WE HAVE TO ELECT
LATINAS WE HAVE TO LET LEVINE
AS- AND- IT. IT S. RUFFLES
FEATHERS AND IT BOTHERS PEOPLE
BUT THAT'S I THINK WHAT THIS
COMMITTEE IS ABOUT IT'S ABOUT
SEEN AT THIS EVERY DAY. AND
THAT'S SOMETHING WE HAVE
LEARNED FROM OUR AFRICAN
AMERICAN SISTERS IS- THIS
UNAPOLOGETIC. QUESTS TO ENSURE.
THAT LATINAS DON'T GO UNSEEN-
WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO BUT
THESE HEARINGS EVERY TIME I
HEAR IT MAKES ME FEEL LIKE. IT
YOU KNOW WE SPENT A YEAR NOW-
AND I SEE SONYA HIGHLIGHTING
THE PROBLEM GETTING ALL OF A
LOT OF THE ISSUES THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH. AND NOW WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE INTO THE YEAR
WHERE WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO
INTENTIONALLY- TARGET. LATINOS
AND WE HOPE YOU'LL WILL HAVE
ALL OF YOUR SUPPORT IN DOING SO.
I'M THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING OUT AND AS PROMISED. TWO
MINUTES TILL TWO THIRTY WE'RE
DONE. OKAY. AT THE END OF YOUR
ACCOUNT WITHIN THE TRACK. OKAY
HI. TELL ME.